Shut it.
Shut it folks.
We're fucking moving.
We're in motion right now.
We're coming to you live from Beautiful Pasadena,
California where it's all going down.
Love is in the air and some other shit that's legal in two states.
Ah,
this Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by on it go to o n n I t.com
and use the code named Brogan and you will save 10% off any and all of the
supplements available at on it.
There's no other way to really truly describe on it then a,
I tried to say a lifestyle company,
a supplement company,
a company that sells you shit to make you more bad ass.
Okay?
Everything that on itself,
it's something to make your mind work better,
improve your mood,
make your body work faster,
whether it's fitness equipment,
whether it's the supplements,
whatever the fuck it is.
We're selling you the best shit humanly possible.
Um,
I'm part owner in this company and that's how much I believe in it.
The stuff is the best shit we can find.
And when we sell you supplements,
no one's trying to rip you off in any way,
shape or form you have.
You can send,
you don't have to send shit.
If you order the first 30 pills,
you get them 100% money back guarantee.
If you don't like it,
you just say you don't like it.
The reason being twofold.
One,
we're definitely not trying to rip anybody off.
We don't want anybody to have a negative experience.
And two,
we are so confident that you're going to enjoy the products that we're willing
to take that chance.
This,
whether it's Alpha brain or whether it's new mood,
there is science behind all of these various supplements,
whether it's the court accepts mushroom supplement,
shroom tech sport,
which is one of the best supplements you can ever use as far as endurance goes.
It's fucking phenomenal.
Um,
the,
the hemp force protein powder that we sell the best hemp protein,
you can get,
the,
the richest in protein,
the smoothest.
And uh,
unfortunately we have to buy it from Canada because it's illegal in this
country.
Yo,
this country's kind of whack as fuck with it's stupid laws,
but we're working that out,
right?
Colorado and Washington state,
Colorado and Washington state stepped up and made marijuana legal.
I would love to sell marijuana on a.com if we could just say bricks of weed
through the mail someday.
Just call him happiness packages and people say,
hey man,
marijuana can be bad for you.
You know that.
That's the age old problem is that everything could be bad for you.
Washing your hands can be bad for you.
If you're fucking bananas and you wash your hands a hundred times a day.
When you talk to me about people that have a problem with marijuana,
I tell you that this people that have a problem with God damn everything,
don't concentrate on that.
Concentrate on what is being used or what is being achieved with marijuana.
That's good and the good aspects of it,
you can't ignore it just because some people have negative experiences.
The good aspects of it are a,
you're,
you're losing your ego,
you're relaxing,
you're getting more social.
You,
you get more sensitive.
Food tastes better.
I don't know about that.
I don't know about that Brian.
Oh,
sex is way better shut sex has gotten want to,
I don't want to hear about your,
but you know that killer bee honeys.
Another thing we're selling [inaudible] dot com we can't sell you week.
Folks could kill you.
We could kill you if you take 25 pounds of it and drop it out of an airplane and
hits you in the head.
Okay?
That's the only way we kills Ya.
And unfortunately,
uh,
because weeds illegal.
We can't sell you hamp either.
So we can sell it,
but we can't grow it.
It's really a screwy situation.
We have to actually get our shit from our neighbor to the North Canada and all
of them were very happy to give our brothers in the north some money.
The Canadian farmers,
it's all nice and everything,
but they're limited to because it's such a high commodity thing now.
It's a,
it's so in demand.
It's,
it's hard to keep up the supply.
Can I just say,
I love how you've added your own little taste to the Onnit website of having a
poker be one of the skills that helps you out for a alpha brain alpha brain.
There's a lot of above.
You mean pools?
That's what you meant.
Oh,
but it's true.
Max Everly,
uh,
he's a totally addicted to it.
Max,
I believe who's a,
one of my very good friends is one of the best pool players in the world.
And um,
Max is a hell of a pool player and he loves taking Alpha brain before he plays
pool poker players swear by it too,
apparently.
Um,
there's a lot of the dudes that,
uh,
that earn the professional poker tour,
are really into Alpha brain.
They're into every possible edge you can get.
I mean,
poker is all about thinking quickly and concisely and being able to,
you know,
formulate all the different possibilities in your mind and nothing helps with
that.
There's Max I,
right.
They're powerful Max crazy hair.
Yeah.
If you see that dude and he wants you to apply for money to not say yes,
I don't.
Sorry,
did knock your action Max.
Just say it's fucked up to say,
hey,
instead of let's go find some hot Asians.
Yeah,
he will fall apart on you.
He will fall apart on you.
Cause I played.
I played pretty good fucking pool,
but Max happily buries me every time he's,
he's a monster.
I've seen that guy run eight racks of 10 balls in a row.
That's not like unheard of.
That shit's ridiculous.
I've seen Max,
I believe do so freaky shit.
All on Alpha brain folks on at.com use the code name.
Rogan.
Save yourself 10% off all the supplements,
the other ship,
the new stuff.
We have so much new stuff.
You have to go to the website because I can't talk anymore.
People get pissed off and they stop listening.
Killer bee,
honey.
We got Omega Three jellies for your young ins.
Go check it out.
Fox.
That's it.
The end.
Danieli ball.
Al is here.
Ready to drop some science on you pitches.
Are you prepared?
We'll good experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast all day.
Shorten these things up.
Danieli you know what I'm saying?
Man,
I'm,
I'm talking too much.
I'm a rambling dude.
And when you,
when I have no script in front of me,
I probably have that cat parasite disease.
I should go look it up.
I we need to stop talking about and just do it.
Just do it.
But I wouldn't want to tell people cause then they'd fucking blame everything on
my cat.
Paris.
We could be the spokesman for it.
I think that'd be awesome if we were the spokesman for,
if that many people are infected by it.
Joey.
Awesome.
Joey has 100 absolutely.
And he's not out.
His kids are about to have it.
Joe is a,
he's had more than 11 cats in his house at one point in time.
I don't know what he has now.
Does he have 11 it's 11 yeah.
And he has wild cats too.
He has ones outside that he only,
he only like feeds.
He doesn't even get to touch.
Those are the ones we'll probably have it.
Yeah.
The feral cats are the ones that probably have it.
He's got feral cats too.
He takes care of what?
Regular cats and feral cats.
That's nuts.
The thing is that that,
that toxoplasma disease,
when,
when people get that shit like you,
everybody always hears about the crazy cat lady.
You know,
everybody always hears about the crazy cat.
People that look lik live around all these cats and a 1520 cats.
If those cats really are hypnotized and those people in forced them to live
around there polluted shit,
that's kind of fucked up.
That's why we need to take the task and we'll be the spokesman for it.
That's a good idea.
That can be our thing.
Most folks don't even know what we're talking about.
Are you familiar at all with the whole toxoplasma thing?
Have you heard about it?
But you know,
kind of like random bad shit that can happen when you have cuts around.
That was about the extent that I got.
That's all you got,
but you're like super smart dude and a professor.
I fake it,
man.
You pick it.
I just fake each.
Well that's what it is.
Well,
you're very well read,
but is there almost too much things are too many things rather too much thing.
See my education,
it's goes deep son.
Fucking strong with the grammar is there's too many things to to know.
I mean in this day and age like to really truly be a renaissance man,
like there you are.
It doesn't matter how well read you are.
Doesn't matter how curious you are,
you are going to come across subjects that are just,
you have no idea.
There's just too much information out about anything.
Even about the stuff that you do know about.
There will still be the areas that you don't know about.
You know what I mean?
It's like the nature of the beast,
but at the same time to me in a way it doesn't matter because the reality of
stuff is the same in 90 specific field of knowledge.
You'll discuss,
you know,
whether you're talking about martial arts or sex or UNH,
whatever.
At the end of the day,
the big themes are going to show up regardless so far your star,
so if you don't know every little thing there is to know which nobody will ever
get there,
then who the hell cares?
As long as you've got the essence of,
of the game.
Yeah.
And you know,
it's like,
I think that's part of how religion got a stronghold on humanity because that,
that reality of all these different things that you don't know and so much out
there that it's,
there was a quote by Terence Mckenna about,
I think it was his brother Dennis actually that said about uh,
expanding.
Uh,
the field of vision just really shows you more of what you don't know.
And that like if you have a camp fire,
like a,
the,
the brighter the campfire,
the more darkness has revealed.
And it's not that you ever,
it all,
it just,
it be the more information you take in,
the more it gets more and more confusing to the point where the real comfort
comes in simplicity.
It's why I like country music songs are so popular.
The idea of embracing simplicity,
especially in this day and age,
it's pretty popular because it feels good to like pretend that you know,
like fucking life's of John Wayne movie.
It feels,
it feels good to pretend that this stuff makes sense.
Where the more you look at life and the more you look at all the different
variables and then the fact that we are finite beings,
just that alone is the ultimate mind.
Fuck that.
No matter how well you do,
you know you,
you have a short amount of time in this spot,
in this dimension.
So the most noble aspects of religion,
I've always,
I've always defended the Nobel aspects of religion because I've seen it do good
things to people that have issues.
I've seen it uses a scaffolding for,
for developing a good ethical and moral behavior.
But the worst aspects of it are always the insistence on limiting information.
The insistence on slowing the,
the,
it's not all religion by the way,
folks in,
and I'm not,
I'm not blaming all,
but I'm saying there's an aspect,
let's not even call it.
Religion is an aspect of human nature.
When you were in a position of power and all of a sudden there's information
that's coming at you.
So you control a bunch of people,
which by the way,
if you run a school or if you run,
um,
you're,
you're a preacher,
you're in a position of power.
You might not think of it as a position of power you might think of is it a
position of teaching?
But you're clearly in a position of power.
And it's just a very unfortunate that when human beings get to that spot where
there's one person controlling another person or in,
in,
in charge of like speaking more than the other people,
they want to like hold that and manipulate it.
And if information comes in the contrary to what they've been teaching,
they fight that fucking shit tooth and nail.
And unfortunately it happens.
Even the lowest levels of academia,
it doesn't just happen in the,
in religion it happens.
And when professors get challenged on,
you know,
a longstanding ideas were,
are proven to be false.
It's,
I mean it's,
it goes way,
we want to think that like when you go way back to like Galileo getting house
arrest for saying that the earth wasn't the center of the universe.
You want to think?
Yeah,
but that was then.
We don't,
we're not,
we're past that shit now.
Not Quite.
We just have enough information.
So it's,
it's way too ridiculous to lock somebody up for saying that the earth is in the
center of the universe,
but it's still okay to teach in schools of the earth is only 10,000 years old.
You know what I mean?
He loves my mind crazy.
They're still doing it.
There's,
there's people,
I don't remember what state it is.
Let's be nice and pretend we don't know what state it is,
but it's,
it's definitely worth warm out.
And these motherfuckers there,
they're trying to teach alternative theories to the theory of evolution and you
know,
they're saying,
well,
it's just the theory.
Evolution is just a theory this and it hasn't been proven.
You show me transitionary
falter,
listen,
forget calling it the evolutionary theory.
Let's just talk about the theory of how shit got to be what it is now.
You know,
when you,
when you call it evolution,
call it whatever you want to stop saying a name that you disagree with.
The evolution means lack.
Oh God.
Who created evolution?
If you just throw away that word,
what's going on?
Well,
obviously things are improving right in front of us all the time constantly.
Whether it's social things was or whether it's the physical capabilities of
human beings.
You know,
the size of lions in Africa that get stuck on an island when when things have to
get better or they get have to get better at something in order to improve.
They do.
And it seems like that's going on from the moment the Big Bang happened to the
cooling of these planets to the time where he could support liquid water to the
emergence of life.
There's a constant series of,
of,
of complications or,
or a constant process of things being more and more complicated and that's just
unavoidable.
So I don't,
it's easy.
Seems like that's everywhere around us.
Everywhere we look.
So you got to call it something.
Say maybe,
maybe there's a god and maybe the what God does is just plant seeds,
just like we do when we make it to paint.
I'll plant,
we're not involved in the entire process,
right?
Maybe the God is the seed planter of the universe,
but the,
the motion and the did,
the way that everything goes,
it's sort of undeniable if get becomes more and more complex.
And when you have people that are in positions of power that insist on using
information that's
really fucking old,
but it's the nature of the business,
right?
If you are in a position of power,
anything that threatens it is a threat to you.
So fuck whatever new in for it.
You don't want anything to change.
A new information can change.
And by definition then it's bad.
Do they use any of the Dead Sea Scrolls?
Does any Christian religion and Braden mean,
granted there are,
last time I checked her 30,000 different denominations of Christianity.
So that's quite a few.
That true.
30,000 a holy Shit.
Which ones have the most sex?
You know,
that's like you've got to look at who's the,
is it the Mormons?
They seem like the healthiest you would dig was there was this one guy very
early Christianity Carpool Kratos or somewhere Greek name like that that um,
I think second century Christianity,
why argue that the way to have and went through sex orgies and that he was
against standing kind of like ownership including Mary edge cause he can see
there we are owning somebody as such as fuck it up.
So not only do we keep our property scene call model,
but we also share our lovers.
So we all have wild orgies in the name of Jesus.
What year was this?
Very early on was like,
I want to say second century.
So he knew how to live.
That guy knew how to live.
But can you imagine like Eddie's version off the IAT Buddy Vale.
But I never done simple little bit awesome fuck Sunday morning and everybody
would be rushing to church like crazy knocking on the door.
Please let me back in.
You know the problem is always going to be some dude's left out that no one
wants to fuck and a will.
Those assholes were ruin it for everybody
else.
I think that's that.
He's thorough.
Fair allegiance,
right there it is,
man.
They come along and they say,
this is not God's way.
Why?
Because nobody wants to fuck that guy.
Exactly.
My thinking think man,
if he looked like Channing Tatum,
is that the guy?
They were really handsome fellow Channing Tatum.
That's the guy you like.
That's a guy like,
look Dave,
if that dude look like Channing Tatum,
he would never be proposing.
I'd be like,
yes,
I'm I need to settle down.
We'll raise,
raise each other's kids.
That's what Mckenna propose to.
He proposed that there was just these wild psychedelic drug orgies and that they
would take mushrooms and have these orgies and that before,
you know,
when they really couldn't identify who was the father because they were all
being polyamorous as it were,
having sex with a bunch of different people,
but Mckenna,
I always felt like there was a little bit of wistfulness in those concepts that
I felt like,
well,
you look at Mckenna and you're like,
it's probably hard for that guy to get close and waves.
He probably concocted some wacky ass carries of things gone by the way things
were,
and maybe not,
dude,
maybe it's always been caveman club and bitches overheads and dragging them into
holes to shoot loads into him because that seems like what it used to be like at
some point in time.
It did.
It really become a mushroom orgies.
I Dunno.
I think he would have liked that.
I think down to these dates,
every theory you ever years from anybody.
It's all about being able to get laid back.
That's my quick seat.
Disease of human nature.
Well,
there's no denying the workings of the human body and the human body requires a
lot of different things.
Uh,
it requires stimulation.
It requires,
that's why people go crazy when you put them in solitary confinement.
It requires the human touch.
I didn't,
I moved to La in [inaudible] 94 I guess,
and I did.
I was out here doing a sitcom and I didn't know anybody out here and I really
didn't like work.
It was,
it wasn't,
it wasn't that fun.
It was,
it was a couple of guys that I liked on the set,
but it was dealing with all these actors.
It was a real alien experience for me.
And you know,
I miss my girlfriend back home in New York and I was out here for a couple of
weeks and this girl that I was working with on the show,
um,
she gave me a hug.
Like it was no big deal.
It's like,
Hey,
how are ya?
What's going on?
I'm excited to see you.
She gave me this hug at work and I remember it like,
like feeling like I went to the gas station and I filled up my tank.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
ah,
like I was on empty and now I'm better.
Like she gave me something by giving me a hug and it wasn't a sexual thing.
It was a,
it was a touch thing and I think we use,
we're so used to being hugged and so used to being social.
It's so common that you don't realize when you step away from it for a little
bit,
but you fucking need the human touch when you haven't been hugged for a while
and someone hugs you.
It feels amazing.
It just feels great just to get a nice hug from a person,
a guy.
It's not a sexual thing.
It can be a guy.
That's what I'd seen that cracked me up when I moved to us.
Is it that I was used to giving hugs?
We men and men,
right,
and Iot are a bunch of men.
I realized they would always,
it's a hen to and in between three pats on the back with sheep's trust 20 inches
away cause otherwise it's sexual or sats again.
I'm like,
Oh fuck that.
I mean he forgot to give me a hug.
Give me August.
Well Dude,
my Dick on dude's legs and shit and the hips,
I like to my Dick on their hips will make sense to give him a hug and rub my
dick on their hips.
Yeah,
I hugged the fuck out of people.
I don't care.
Yeah,
we always say that like when we're going to Twitter,
we're on Twitter.
Going to shows a free hugs at the ice house tonight.
Well we say silly shit like that.
Nothing wrong with hugging people,
man.
But there is something wrong when somebody wants to hug you and you don't want
to hug them,
then just start robbing fucking.
Then you're like,
listen man,
I don't even know you.
Or people that want to hug you that have bad breath.
Like,
you can hug me but you gotta keep your mouth shut where it says the sweaty palms
are sweaty hands and it's like a dead fish.
It's so often,
well I think it was strengthening my immune system because I do these shows and
after the shows I'll shake hands with like hundreds of people cause I after the
shows I wait in line and then I take pictures with everybody.
I just feel like,
you know,
it's only a couple more hours of my time and it's,
I'm so fortunate in so many ways that I feel like a hat and someone,
you know like dice wears gloves,
like he won't even shake people's hands.
Dice foresees weightlifting gloves.
The funniest was when we're that say this already or that Greg Fitzsimmons when
we were in Seattle and we are taking photos together.
Like you were taking photos and then they would come to us and me and him would
take photos together and he was saying like how he doesn't shake hands,
he just fist bumps.
And so I'm like,
you know,
that makes so much sense because I am touching all these people's hands.
And so I did,
the next person went up to,
happened to be an Asian guy and his girlfriend or whatever,
and I did a fist bump and he goes,
hey,
he,
you're the only one.
He hasn't done shaking a person's hand.
Like he tried to throw me underneath the bus,
like he doesn't want to share here.
So then,
and then I was like trying to get them,
trying to get them back.
So what I would do is like,
we would have her arm around the guy like,
like,
uh,
you know,
and,
and Greg said,
uh,
I don't touch the person.
So like when they do the arm thing,
I just stand there.
I don't put my arm around them.
So I would always be like,
come on Greg,
put your arm around the guy,
let's take a photo here and then say he would have to do it.
He really doesn't hug me.
No,
no.
And so then I started like moving his hand down and so like,
he would touch his book,
the guy's butt stuff.
It was hilarious.
We are having the greatest time doing that.
Just stupid shit.
Yeah.
We've,
we went for a series of maybe five years of photos where Brian made a Baa face
and the back of the photo,
it's not a joke like there's,
there might be 100,000 photos plus of Brian.
I mean,
he was fucking committed to it.
Yeah.
There's a new era of humanity.
The photo error,
there's more photos today than there ever were ever.
I mean,
in one day,
I bet there's more photos taken then the entire history of the human race.
Can you imagine history books in a hundred years?
It's just going to be fucking like my
space photos from like the top and like this person who did this important thing
and times this is Tila Tequila.
Right?
And this was her website that really shocked the world.
Yeah.
Speaking of photos,
just so you guys know why you,
we may seem this,
Gus guests may seem distracted and weird.
Right behind Joe's had,
there's these giant picture off a guard with vendor.
Very generous cleavage.
Do you know who that is?
I don't.
Do I want to know about this beautiful year?
Not America.
That's Pamela Anderson.
You got to a kid.
I mean that's fine.
Not knowing who pet look.
I look like I'm eight years old.
See how she's so yellow?
It's because of the hepatitis C.
That's why Brian stopped that.
But so many,
to be honest is actually at the moment of being here.
Like 40 minutes is the first second that my eyesight goes above our clavicles
balloons.
Yeah,
that fan.
When I was a younger man,
I would've loved them.
So,
but now I look at them and I say they're good,
look great and everything,
but I can't get past the irony or the,
the ridiculousness of the fact that there's a a bag of water under your nephew
thought that he got passed that crazy dude.
That's so crazy.
I just,
just saying that I had a dream,
Brian,
that we were at a strip club and you,
you and I were at a strip club and there was a girl with a fake butt and you
kept saying,
dude,
she's got a fake,
but she's got to fake.
This is a real can of get her over here.
She'll show us.
She'll tell us.
And this girl was covered in oil and you were like pinching her fake,
but like you can't feel it at all.
And I was,
and I was just shocked how,
how odd it was.
I don't know why I see my life.
You time traveled.
Yeah.
Time traveled.
And uh,
well tell me,
because this girl had like an arm bracelet on as if she was like a Meu Thai
fighter or some shit.
And she had black hair.
She had just covered in oil and she's quite tanned.
She had black hair and she was tan.
But I said,
I don't think was oil is just pussy juice.
How come girls don't go with the Tan lines?
Tan Lines are gone.
They don't exist anymore.
You don't see him in porn.
If you ever see him in porn to get all excited and it's the hottest shit ever,
ever under boob,
Tan Line perfection.
Garfield looking down at the sidewalk.
That's great.
Garfield,
looking at the sidewalk,
the fuck,
I don't know when you talked to him about this.
Imagine that's it.
Thank you.
I'm glad.
Do you know when you started?
No,
there's three,
three filled those room knows the fuck you're talking about Brian Youth.
Your brain bad it Garfield.
I think you have a hamster parasite.
Everybody else got that cat parasite.
You got like a hamster.
Paris Garfield looking down at the side walk under bib.
I did not know what that is.
That's a weird thing that girls can do where they can go out and they can
literally,
their entire tit can be hanging out as long as their areas are covered.
It's okay.
Yeah.
That is such a weird thing with us.
Like you can,
you can paint your tits.
Have you ever seen that?
When people paint their whole body so they're fucking naked and you have pain on
your tits are out and you're just wandering around at a party and like guys with
their girlfriends and their girlfriends,
they found like a loophole for showing their tits.
Right.
Not that I'm blaming the look.
I'm not a hater.
I'm just saying it's a weird thing that you can just paint your tits and we're
pretending that's close when it paint become close because it's not dick close.
I'll tell you that you can't paint your deck.
We should try now.
You can't.
You go right to jail.
You can't just paint your Dick and go out there.
We'll arrest you.
They will lock you up for sure.
They'll say you're naked,
but a girl can be topless and covered in paint and somehow or another we let
that slide.
Even if it's like painted like a Tracy,
we like,
I'm a law enforcement.
You now on the field when we're out there on the streets trying to keep people
safe.
I don't want pits out if it's painted really well though.
Like if it was a Turkey gobbler or something like that or you know,
like it's nice.
Yeah.
It's pretty like it's a cool artwork.
Artwork.
Yeah.
Well I guess there's an argument for that.
Look,
I think you should be able to do it.
Don't get me wrong,
but I think it is weird that you're allowed to do it.
You're not allowed to be topless,
but you are allowed to be topless with paint on your tits.
That's the fucked up bark.
You ever not allowed to be topless.
What the fuck is that?
I mean he's just like,
we have what?
Sanford under valley ward copied all of porn,
but at the same time,
if a woman gets topless on the beach,
it's considered indecent exposure and you go to jail.
These were very ridiculous.
What if we could pants,
uh,
painted on and we get to a strip club?
I don't think he can do that.
I think they'll arrest you.
You should try.
You try to paint your Dick Walker genes on Paige jeans?
Yeah,
I guess why not?
It really gets down to the question of like how thin his clothes,
like at what point in time is it not close when it's opaque?
Is it close?
I could see the outlining the deck if I'm,
if you're wearing clear pants,
are you allowed to wear clear pants?
Like say if you were wearing,
it looked like Saran wrap,
clear pants and I just see your cock and balls.
Is that legal because you're wearing clothes,
you're just wearing clear close?
Probably not league.
I think so.
Unless there's,
unless he trimmed like I think if he had no pubic hair,
it might be legal.
What have years old monster Bush.
It's the Bush as hair,
everything.
No underwear walking around.
So are you around a lot of walk around in underwear?
That's a question.
Yeah.
Are you?
I think so.
Can you just walk somewhere with underwear on?
Can you walk into a store with underwear on?
I would think so.
You can walk in if you have board shorts and no underwear on,
they don't even know.
And meanwhile,
this is just a thin layer cloth between you and your dangerous Dick.
Girls wear bathing suits everywhere.
So that's underwear.
Are they allowed to wear bathing suits into a store?
Every store.
My ex girlfriends do.
You did a bunch of sweet.
We went to olive garden in a bathing suit.
It cause it's just a way to get in a bathing suit to olive garden.
Yeah.
That's how you know you're classy
boy.
But it should have married that girl with the naked story brings back a mammary.
I had the most annoying neighbors in the universe who are hardcore Christian.
Fundamentalist total freaks who made noise.
Don't give out their address online but give out the house right next to them
on be nice.
Plus they probably moved by now and it's somebody else who would get stuck with
people.
But in any case,
these guys were just bugging the shit out of me and they were uh,
in the,
in the back they were cleaning
their car.
He was like the way the Hobbs this worst stop it.
This was about a full one foot out of my screen door that was open in the back
with some are.
So there was only,
I only had the screen door but you could see inside cars at the light on.
I was like,
how do I piece these people off?
They're bugging the hell out of me with their obnoxious music.
I was like,
you know what,
fuck the play naked chef.
So I was cooking at the moment.
They were right there.
So I just,
it other than just cool clinic and they are not quite pay attention yet.
So I'm going to make sure to pump the music a little.
So the look inside with one second from the time I did that,
they were out back in the house,
locked behind her,
them and it was wow.
You like it when they watch that
there was a guy was arrested.
Did you hear about the story that was arrested for that very thing in
Springfield,
Virginia,
a guy named Eric Williamson was arrested and charged with indecent exposure for
failing to put on any clothes after getting up at 5:30 AM to make some coffee,
any silos and his house in his own fucking house.
A woman in her seven year old daughter had cut across Williams front yard and
saw him through his kitchen window.
Well first of all,
that concept trespasser and fucking Colorado and parts west,
they could just shoot that crazy bitch.
So she called the cops cause the guy was making coffee naked.
The guy got out of fucking bed and made coffee.
It's not like he was beating off in front of the window banging on it.
You and the kid.
That's crazy.
If convicted Williamson could be fine $2,000 and could spend a year in jail.
And this is,
this is incredible.
This is 2009.
I don't know what happened,
but I think this is,
he's been,
I think this has happened more than once.
My favorite
today was some guy,
uh,
give it a $2,000 ticket to a toddler who was be seen any Solon backyard.
Oh God.
A toddler.
Yup.
It did happen again.
It happened in October this year.
Young in Yorktown,
Virginia.
And again,
it's all places where it's fucking too hot out.
Those people are retarded.
Not all of them,
but a good good percentage of them.
Right?
A good solid percentage.
If you're in Virginia,
a good solid percentage of the people that you're solid.
It's not even a word.
So what I said,
I think I said this already coming out my mouth,
I'm like stupid.
By the way,
both of these incidents happened in Virginia,
two separate towns in Virginia.
God,
people are stupid as fuck.
This guy was 69 years old.
He was in his house.
He was standing naked in front of the window up.
Well that might've been different.
This guy seems a little creepy.
Yeah,
it's again,
a woman with her kids walking her kids and this dude,
he,
she said he made no effort to cover himself and was in clear view of the public.
You know why?
Because he probably is not even sure if he's alive anymore.
He's 69 years old.
What was the last time anyone touched his dick?
He's probably on all kinds of pills and he purse like,
I just want to be naked in front of the window.
Am I even alive anymore?
There's somebody out there,
so he takes his off and stands in front
of the mirror something.
It's always some cock blocking bitch just hating with their kids.
Not to say the guy wasn't creepy and crazy and I'm sure he has,
but really it's your house.
You should be allowed to be naked.
You know what's fun about having a beetle is that every time you drive by kids
they punch each other because it's a you slug bug beetle.
The black,
you're supposed to be like slope.
What block and then he punched a person.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I've never heard of them.
Yeah,
it's like a kid's thing that every time you see a beetle you have to save the
color of the beetle.
Like slug bug red.
If it's a red beetle and then you punch the person in that.
Oh,
so they could punch you if they see the same car again.
Right.
Or if they see another beetle.
Oh,
any beetle.
Yeah.
So it's funny because you see it when you drive a butyl,
you see it like just driving by people.
You'll see it like every five people will do it.
Yeah.
I would recommend not playing that game with anybody who knows how to punch.
Right.
Well I was thinking just go do it like a school girl.
I like when they get out of class,
you know,
just to keep on driving by real slow and this Japanese schoolgirl,
Japanese schoolgirl like a school
going by a school and punching each other.
Brian,
you're going to need to go to a doctor.
You really need to go to a doctor though.
The idea that you are on a podcast that seen and listened to by millions of
fucking people,
staggers folks at home right now.
It like this guy.
Does he understand that?
No one understands him.
Yeah,
it's cool girl.
And then you fly those airplanes,
get a kite,
light a cigarette.
You know when you cut grass like something wrong with your brain,
the sentences that you're putting together,
the nonsensical and you say,
I'm like,
yeah,
you know,
maybe I'm partially to play him for nursing.
I don't.
No,
maybe it's partially my fault.
Why is it naked?
Why is being naked illegal?
Is that,
does that a religion thing?
Is that even in the Bible?
Do you have cool work clothes?
You know,
it's awesome because all the sacral stuff is,
it's hilarious because I'm,
especially in Christianity because Jesus doesn't really talk about sex.
I mean there's like one of mine or reference where people think actually was a
joke and he was trying to say the opposite,
but in any case,
this is a known issue.
It just never touch us on the topic.
For All we know.
He could have been having origins from morning tonight or could have been
totally said,
we have no idea this is Jesus.
But what about the,
doesn't the old testament have some sexual references and it doesn't,
it does.
It forbade Chris a sexy homosexuality.
What would it,
what does it say about the lines with a man?
He should be stoned,
right?
Oh yeah.
Which maybe is be interpreted in a different way,
but yeah,
it'd be cool if they meant that.
Like if you guys are having sex,
you should get high for us a little feel better.
Let it be funny.
It was a big misunderstanding and the dummies came along,
Oh,
we gotta throw rocks at them and then that's,
it became that,
you know,
it was like if two guys are lying around together,
like you'll listen.
If you want her to get really comfortable with each other,
you've got to get high for us.
That should be it.
That should be,
they make you emperor off the ward and that should be a lot of the first laws
passed.
Yeah.
I,
I've always said there's two types of people that are trying to gay marriage in
case sex.
It's people that are really dumb and people that are secretly worried that
Dick's are delicious.
Yeah,
of course.
That's all it is.
It's people that are just fucking fighting off the gay man and they're not
winning.
They're fighting off the gay,
but they're just fucking not winning.
The fact that you would want to control anybody who's into anything sexually,
you know,
like dudes.
I have friends that are into really big women.
Like,
I don't want to mention names,
Sam Tripoli,
but there's,
there's a guy,
he fucking loves big women jokes,
but he loves a man.
Like a girl walked by two 10 to 20 he's like,
fuck yeah,
Mama,
you ready?
You know
it.
But that's him.
You know?
I mean like,
it's have to do it.
Everybody's got their own thing.
You know?
Some men are into like really big women and the really tall women.
Some women,
some men are into like little tiny ones,
like whatever the fuck you're into,
man.
I don't care.
Why would anybody care?
But back in the day,
some someone decided that gay dudes are against God's way.
How did that,
how did that eventually,
originally start?
Does that old tea?
It's Old Testament,
right?
I mean,
but are,
you know,
and does it exist?
And he picked Christianity.
Yeah,
it does.
Homophobia does.
Yeah.
What,
where does it exist?
Um,
you do everything a bunch of places.
So the oldest of the same places at different points in time maybe completely
changed their tune dramatically.
But you do have it in places and times that other than Christian stuff like,
you know,
a lot of,
uh,
had a lot of Chinese culture,
not exactly friendly toward homosexuality,
but the Japanese,
oddly enough,
especially the Samurais were very friendly with us and he's our Frakes and
that's a whole different game.
Some about Saks is he's in play octopuses the Williams school girls to every see
girls in between.
The Japanese were bad motherfuckers.
Man,
there,
their culture was so,
uh,
so innovative when it came to so many different things.
The,
the,
the decider discipline,
you know,
the,
the controlling of the mind that all the different,
the innovations in martial arts,
so much of it came from Japan.
So much of it,
when you think about how small Japan is in relation to the rest of the world,
it's really kind of shocking.
Like Japans like the size of Texas,
right?
Not even,
not even a sign of Texas.
Yeah.
Texas.
I think Japan is,
it might be like,
you know,
a fairly small area in comparison to like one of our good size states and
meanwhile think about how much shit came from there.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
It's weird how that happens.
Her one spot.
What kind of religion when they practicing when Shinto and what is that based
on?
[inaudible] so water of nature,
spirits and stuff like that that they all even started calling machine to will
literally means the way of the gods.
Only when Buddhism came around just because he's like,
I guess we have to call our shit something to differentiate it from this.
But these came around,
I want to say 12 and threads.
I want to say other lenders to the jump.
N C a d or BC.
Oh No,
I d eight d and so 1,280 that's not that long ago,
man.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
Maybe a little bit before,
but that's the,
these mean Japan,
would these mean Jana was six about 500 before,
like 2,500 years ago.
Where does Buddhism originally come from?
What country?
India.
Yeah.
You start out with in India.
And I need to pass through.
But the weird thing is that today there's no Buddhism in India really?
And or like tiny,
tiny.
Because what happens is,
well beside the Muslim in visuals in the north to destroy a bunch of time post
and all that shit.
But then the way in Louisa Marie actuate his Braille and you know in the West
when you know,
protest aunties and comes out of catalysis and they kill each other for 200
years.
When Buddhism comes out into wisdom,
start checking out what they do and then they steal a bunch of their ideas.
They bring them back into their things.
So if somebody is Hindle they see the Buddhist thing,
it's like,
oh,
we already do some of that shit.
I don't need to switch religions.
So they just blatantly borrow from it.
And so less and less people in India at any needed to convert because they could
find room for that stuff within indoor season.
Oh.
That's sort of how Christianity absorbed a lot of pagans with,
uh,
like the changing their holidays,
like the Christmas religion,
like the Christmas holiday and making that Jesus's birthday when Jesus has
really supposedly born in like June or something.
All right.
It's like big on holiday.
But that even as he's,
that in Christianity,
they lie about it.
They try to pretend it didn't happen in Indonesia and they're like,
yeah,
that's cool.
That was a good idea.
And we borrowed it.
They're smart.
Yeah.
Look,
the Buddhist said a lot of fucking cool ideas.
Yeah.
Wow.
How would the Buddhist,
what was it about Buddhism?
There was,
so there's no other religion that I know that is so intent on like the cleansing
of consciousness and the purity of thought,
the idea of a,
you know,
uh,
meditation and isolating the isolating your,
your consciousness to,
to,
to clear out all these in practical ideas like material wealth and the need for
sexual satisfaction.
All those different things managed through Buddhism.
Um,
that's,
that's very rare that a uh,
uh,
an ideology like takes on such a strong and discipline stance about like
expanding consciousness.
Like how did that start?
Well,
cause I mean Buddhism starts out as a mystical movement,
right?
And they still thought that about mystical techniques designed to take you to a
certain state of consciousness.
That's why like the whole point of Buddhism is not to become a Buddhist is to
become a Buddha.
You know,
you have to do this,
that and is not like worship the guy who would eat it.
Good for you.
Well who cares?
How does that affect you?
Is about being able to do the same thing that the guided meditation in that
sense,
he's one of those techniques designed to,
to take you there,
to bring you to that state of consciousness and um,
make door new into a boat.
They're sanitary.
That's a fascinating thing because that should,
that's sort of the case with an anything that you're trying to achieve.
You know,
when you are,
whether you're doing martial arts or the you're doing art or anything,
you're,
you're trying to find your own path through
the example of others.
Yeah.
And that's one of the things that's like really important about being around bad
motherfuckers.
Like people don't understand,
they really underestimate the importance of being around bad motherfuckers.
You got to like know like what other people are capable of,
what they can do.
And in order to be like truly,
I mean in my experience to be truly inspired and now and when you find people
that are like jealous around bad motherfuckers or try to hold people down,
if you find like if you have friends and those for like,
okay,
just to you,
whoever you are,
if you're a cock blocker,
if you're one of those guys that tries to fuck your friends,
girlfriends or you,
uh,
you get jealous when your friend successful and you talk shit about him behind
his back and you stab him in the butt.
If you're one of those guys,
you're just fucking yourself.
If you see some guy and he's doing better than you,
you,
you either one of have to accept one of two things.
You got to go.
That guy's like,
he's crazy.
He works too hard except did cause there is that right there is that there's a
lot of jealousy that's misplaced because really that person probably doesn't
have as good a life as you,
if you know some good fishing spots,
right?
But if you start feeling negative feelings towards them because they're
successful,
that's,
that's bad for you man.
That that is that the negative feelings that you're feeling towards him,
they work,
they will fucking affect you.
They will come after you.
They will chip away at your self esteem.
They will chew your,
your mind will know that you're thinking of like when you see,
like I've seen this before where a guy like becomes like real successful at the
comedy store.
It was always like some guy will get a movie or something or it's a series and
take off and then you see other comics,
they'd be like,
yeah,
well he's fucking,
he's got a show now,
man.
Fucking guys go to show.
Meanwhile,
they were like buddies just like a month ago.
And this guys,
somehow or another,
that guy's success is causing this dude uncomfortable feelings and,
and so what he does his lashes out at the person who's successful.
You'll lashing out it yourself.
You gotta take your medicine.
That feeling that you get when you know that you haven't done the best you can
do.
That's to keep you from doing that.
Again,
that terrible feeling of regret.
Don't lash out at other people.
Just take your fucking medicine and get your shit together.
Easier said than done.
Thought that easier said than done because then you have to do something that
I'd are down whining like a beach about what somebody else is doing.
Yeah.
It's um,
the management of your energy that at that is the most important aspect of
living this life.
Managing your energy and the managing to keep it somehow and it keeping your
thoughts,
keeping your consciousness,
your focus in a good direction,
in a healthy direction.
How do you do it?
Cause I mean,
I was going over in my mind,
I was like,
how many m sinks that Joe dual,
you know,
from comedy to the podcast,
UFC,
you know,
like there's so much you work out religiously,
you do all this stuff.
They're like late 30 out of the hell.
Do you do it with 24 hours in a day?
Stay in a semi sane.
Everything I do,
I like to do.
That's the big part of it.
Like,
you know,
I was looking forward to this podcast.
Let's going to be a lot of fun.
I'm looking forward to going into Jujitsu.
I'm,
I'm looking forward to working out.
I'm looking forward to writing tonight.
I'm gonna get some riding.
I'm looking forward to getting into the tank later.
You know,
I don't do anything.
I love working for the UFC.
I look forward to the big fights.
So look forward to the little fights and nobody even cares about.
I love what I do,
you know,
and that to be the,
that thing that makes me the happiest in life is that I've found all these
things that interests me and we,
I know we all have different personalities.
Like we had Tim Ferriss here yesterday and that motherfucker likes to salsa
dance.
Okay.
I don't get it.
But I love Tim Ferris.
So it's,
we,
I found things that,
that stimulate me for whatever reason.
And those are the things that I pursue.
So I'm constantly motivated and energized by my activities.
All the things that I do,
like I've had jobs before and even a job like fear factor,
which was a great job still,
I would be like,
what the fuck am I doing here man?
Just collecting a check.
Right.
You know,
this is not what I would rather be doing.
And when you,
if you could figure out a way to live your life where everything you're doing is
what you want to do at that moment,
you know,
it's just,
that's,
that's a really difficult thing to,
to sort of manage.
And I've been,
I have to,
I have to think that.
I know that I've worked very hard,
but I think I'm very fortunate.
There's no question about it.
There's a lot of fortunate involved in that.
It's not,
um,
there's no way it's a,
all my work boats cause he's not going to,
I mean far Trump can play a role,
but he's not going to happen unless you do the work either.
It's,
it goes both ways.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
I think everybody has their own take on what life is really all about,
what,
what it is for them.
You've got to find out what your thing is.
You know,
whether it's studying ancient religions and or some people they get their
fucking thrills out of combing the mountain side with a brush looking for
fossils like that that reels them to no end.
Everybody's got their own fucking vibe.
And if you want to be a happy person,
you got to find your vibe.
That to me is always been like the biggest problem that I have with it,
with any sort of totalitarian or any,
any sort of like really strict ideology is that you cannot apply the same rules
and the same behavior patterns to everybody.
Because when you do that,
you lose the,
the beauty of the freak.
You know,
like I was talking like we're talking about Joey Diaz today,
me and my friend Aubrey,
we're having a conversation about Joey,
but how awesome he is.
He's just such a rare person.
Like he's just such a rare freak and it's such,
you know,
he's just a crazy dude.
I can't get them into other countries cause he fucking back in the day,
kidnap to dude machine gun still calling from mean.
It's crazy.
He's at,
he can't go to Seattle.
He's got warrants.
I mean he's,
he's a maniac,
but he's,
he's a beautiful craziness.
Like all,
all this nutty life experiences,
both positive and negative have made this incredible person that you're really
the,
it's a,
he's a joy to be around and he's a beautiful human being.
Like he's always hugging people and everywhere he goes,
he's like your number one fan.
You know,
he,
he's happy to see like he's the type of guy that will go to the same places in
his neighborhood all the time.
As soon as he walks in,
they all know I'm doing like Joey,
what's going on Joey?
What are you doing?
Cock sock or what are you doing?
And they're just like,
oh,
this burst of happiness.
Cause this guy's around.
Well,
you know,
if you followed the tenants of most religions that guys,
he's fucking sinner by the highest stretch of the imagination,
right?
Where the f the,
the furthest explanation of the term,
you know,
like to a tee,
he's a fucking center across the board.
Everything he's doing is wrong except being nice to people.
But smoking weed whacking off and he's fucking crazy.
Live with 11 cats and he's you.
You can't control people and get those variables,
you know?
I mean the stuff you'll find within the rules is the ordinary.
If you're willing to get start in our is going to be outside of the rose.
That's just the name of the game.
But of course that threatens any institution is threatened by that.
And so they will try to squash it and I'll make it happen.
Like in school,
of course when you're in school,
they know they don't want a acting out.
They don't want anybody who's not there.
That's the weirdest thing about school is that it just by virtue of the fact
that you have to sit there and do the work,
when they say you have to sit there and do the work,
just by virtue of that,
they control your,
your consciousness and you are,
you,
you relinquish your consciousness to them and that sets you up for a lifetime of
work.
Were you doing what you don't want to do when they want you to do it?
Yeah.
Cause I mean it's cool.
He's not released.
Their credit score is not about educating and awesome human being is designed to
make you fang shown in an average way in the society while educating you.
But that's the,
that's the primary aspect.
I mean it's sort of,
that certainly educates you more than not going to school.
Not,
yeah.
Okay.
Because that's the other thing is like the anti intellectual Liza Mazda crazy.
This is like,
no,
please give me back into school.
It's any day now,
but then when you already need to then you get to talk shit about it.
And so you can see all the lean meats and all the problems and allow,
it could be so much better at any teas.
And it's frustrating when you see it today meets,
well you are,
you are a professor of religion.
Yeah.
It started in January.
It true in general,
but,
and you have,
you wrote something recently that I read where you were,
uh,
really,
it seemed like he just had,
had a really frustrating moment or you release yourself with your,
your writing about academia.
What,
what,
what did you say?
That there's nothing like having an open letter to an academic college and um,
and quilting Tupac,
fuck you and fuck you on your motherfucking mom.
Cause that what you did,
that's the end of the longer life.
It sounds so beautiful with your accent though.
There's a lot of people that go,
hey man,
who's that guy was
sounds like GSP.
I think you sound like GSP,
which is ridiculous because I don't think,
I don't say it's branch around the same thing.
Well that's Americans for you man.
Anything that's not long ago I spoke,
well I don't even know some fucking French or some shit got could be speaking in
Arabic.
He's fucking French ended up over the,
I think I told you that before.
What type of guy he asked me,
how are you from?
It's like,
Oh yeah,
for me,
you are from Italy?
No Way.
I was just in Paris last week.
Oh Wow.
I live on earth.
So when you wrote this and you quote a Tupac in this open letter to academia,
what was your,
what was the,
well just tell us what the letter said I was,
that was just for the straight and which is most of the time I'm not because I'm
hanging out with students and students are awesome.
Know 99% of my students have a great time hanging out.
They are fun,
makes good for conversation.
That's the part of school I like.
I'm frustrated by all the rest the administration on and um,
bullshit that's around.
I mean I notice my teaching students that are always ecstatic.
Oh man you are doing such a good job.
Sometime I'm like really?
Cause I was having a really shitty day and I feel like I gave you a crap.
That's good.
Yeah.
Yeah this is awesome.
But then I look in the next class and they look at what a regular teaching look
like and it makes you want to shoot yourself cause it's dry as hell.
There's no attempt to connect it to real life.
There's academia is like its own little,
that box for the most part.
And the only reason why people read academic stuff is because somebody is
forcing them to because nobody's going to go out and buy the book and spend it
on Saturday night.
You know the problem we took a demia is that these populated 90% by people who
spend their Saturday night to shine in their PhDs and devising new ways to
squeeze or joy out of learning because that's what they do or really know is it
that they don't really want to squeeze all the joy out of learning.
They just are not motivated to make learning more exciting is that I think is
what they are.
They are joyous mother fuckers and so they transmit that to their students and
they don't know how to think in any other way and off it is the institution part
of it is the repetition,
pirate of it,
whatever that may be,
but theirs is part of it.
Just the idea of just going to school for a long time yourself and you,
you sort of get used to this fact,
this cold hard fact that you have to do things you don't want to do and probably
that I'm sure that does a lot to do with it.
You come to accept the norms of like in any field when the school doing to the
field and they try to mold doing what the expert look like,
they are bicycle trying to squash your individuality.
Exactly the things you were saying about joy in order to staff that makes you
you,
that's wild and weird and that all gets to be squashed in the name of becoming a
professional and so that academia does that as well.
You know,
Grad School is a,
my nam being tortured or for the most part the world is going to be on
newscasters.
It's going to be people with no real opinions that we'll never say anything that
would offend to anybody.
They just fucking bullshit their way through life until their ticker stops.
But to give an
idea of how low the berries about this stuff.
Cause that's exactly the scenario you're describing is exactly what happens.
To give an idea of how low the barriers or the first day of classes and any
semester I teach,
first day I love going,
I'll put on a red hot chili peppers and I'll give out the syllabus.
Shaking hands with people.
Not a big deal.
Right?
All udds press play for some music and write who cans with another human being
for two seconds hitch.
How many people are in your class?
Maybe 50 or something.
So you know,
five minutes of a song you get to shake hands with everybody.
Then you'll start,
before I even start,
I'm like 10 steps ahead.
Cause people are like no professor ever shook my hand and I'm like are you
kidding me?
You know that's the big deal that a one press play music and shake hands before
you even get started at Cetera.
Pirates.
Wow,
that's sad.
You know that's just,
but I've seen it.
I mean I've cool tote with some people who first day of classes and they walk
into a class and I'm like,
hello students,
my name is doctor and right there for me the semester is over cause it's like
your name is not doctor anything.
Your Dick,
your name is Joe,
whatever.
His like,
he already put on the title and put on this big better times to create a
separation with students that smoothed out and my life,
I need to be a doctor.
Can I get an honorary doctorate somewhere?
I'm sure you're bumped.
Dr Rogan.
Does anybody out there?
Yeah,
it is a any distinction.
Mr Sir.
You know,
when I used to teach taekwondo,
everybody was Mr uh,
was Mr O'malley and Mr. Smith,
Mr. Kim,
you know,
that's a very formal,
you have to,
whenever you know the address,
you yes sir.
No Sir.
It was always sir,
like a,
that's a,
that immediately puts that,
that air of them being above you.
Yeah.
It's very cultish,
a lot of a martial arts behavior and it's managed in a good way.
So it's beneficial and,
and you know,
it's good for your character,
but that same aspects of it easily can be manipulated.
And we all know martial arts instructors who wound up manipulating their
students.
You're a martial artist as well.
I should add worse.
Um,
and you have been for a long time.
[inaudible] we all know like there's always stories of like,
it's always like a guys molesting his students.
Like a young teenage girl that's like,
you know,
learning under him or you know,
uh,
that kind of a situation like very similar to the type of situations where you
would have like preachers would do something like that or poor professors,
right.
There's always professors that are banging their students and scandals will rise
where they give preferential treatment to girls who give head.
It's a,
it's,
it's a story as old as time.
Right.
I'm going to keep my mouth shut about that.
Come on,
come on site.
A Beautiful Guy.
You've got a great accent.
Not to kick a little ass.
I bet they throw it at you son.
There was one of ds was the bus the weird,
I laughed for like an hour after that.
There was a,
at the end of the semester,
I mean I'm an easy grader as a tease.
I give A's left and right and there was these girls who really did horrible and
there was nothing I could do to push her up.
He's,
you really fucked up.
I mean,
you're getting,
yeah,
I forgot to see with me,
which is magical.
You didn't do shit.
It's like,
really?
And I kid you not.
She's like,
what do I need to do for the higher grade?
And I'm like [inaudible].
I'm like still trying to check or where she's going.
Then I went by,
she looks at me and she's like,
oh,
come on.
You know you want
dude,
my Dick would have exploded my pants.
Like a firecracker
probably bled out from my deck.
You should,
you should have called her bluff and just shoved your finger right up.
What do you think?
Um,
first of all,
what she looked like?
No,
unfortunately she wasn't taught
shit.
Like why was she so confident?
Why not?
She was super hot.
I don't want to ruin your fun.
Oh,
you ruined it or running.
Sorry.
My memory is not that bad.
She was in a wheelchair.
Dammit.
Dude.
How much did she weigh?
At least she have a nice body.
Yeah,
she wasn't big.
She wasn't big.
She was,
um,
she wasn't big regular size.
Size wise.
She was okay.
That was the only one.
Your entire academic career.
No,
no.
I mean,
but that wasn't the most like don't be silly jokes.
That was the most,
that was blatant and fun.
You know what I mean?
Right,
right,
right.
Well are cool about it.
You know,
they are flirting with you,
but it's,
it's polite.
It's,
that was,
and he wasn't even about flirted.
He was,
I want the higher grade.
That's it.
She didn't give up on any level,
you know?
That's Hilarious,
man.
Do you,
uh,
are you like cognizant of that?
Like when you talk to girls like that you have this unfair advantage over them
as a,
as a professor?
I mean,
bottom line is they don't want to be a dick.
You don't want to be a dick with anybody.
So I break the rules all the time,
but kind of like what you were saying about Julie's like,
nobody's ever going to get hurt by me so that I break rules to me doesn't mean
shit because they must be stupid rules if nobody gets served.
If I break them down,
why are the roads to be gain weight?
You know?
Because we need bureaucracy.
People employed,
so all that crap about,
oh,
you're not supposed to hug your students because that would be sexual harassment
or some shit.
I thought that ignore it.
But at the same time,
yeah,
you want to hurt anybody.
Just hugging people.
How many teachers wind up bang and girls in class?
Because obviously as I said,
illegal.
Oh Wow.
It's highly,
they lose their job immediately.
Do they really like 23 dof shit.
Tough Shit.
You can't bang.
Your students know.
I mean,
it's absolutely illegal if you're talking to high school or something when you
were talking to under age,
but I'm talking to college students.
I'm calling and talking to people in their twenties it's legal,
but so nobody's going to put you in jail or something.
But you're going to get fired by your university recently against their policy.
Big tits.
What does she's hot as fuck.
No,
for real.
She's like Pamela Anderson.
Look in and you know,
and you're like,
look,
I'm saying those,
he's singled.
I taught her some English.
She's talking like,
oh you should,
you should be my lawyer.
But it seems like you know,
just because you're teaching somebody,
I mean,
what if you give her a B?
I give her a fucking bay.
Come on.
Not even being unreasonable.
There are standard you can't date while class is in session.
Oh,
okay.
You know,
the 16 weeks or whatever and on our,
the symmetrics.
Exactly.
What would you stay there after class was lower cost is over.
We're going to meet the next group of kids.
Hopefully there's another hot 23 year old and to keep this party rolling there.
Bunch of Cock blockers.
That's what it is.
No,
you can't.
You really can't.
You can't bang your students.
Right.
What about dudes and they a lot of Bang dudes.
Like,
what if there's a,
you know,
you're gay and you got to some gay kids or some really gullible straight dudes
that are willing to,
is that a,
is that the same thing with boys too fellows?
Unfortunate.
Silly.
That's just fucking goddammit it,
she wouldn't it be great if we just had teachers.
It wouldn't do anything creepy.
You know,
wouldn't that'd be like way simpler right now.
We'd be,
that's not going to happen.
Is it possible to ever get to a position where you have uh,
an an enlightened group of people that are teaching students in like this open
and friendly way where we actually have a group of people that come out of these
classes and can contribute to society?
Is that possible?
Like you,
you're,
you're in the inside,
right?
Um,
I dunno man.
Cause the point is for good teaching means it's where you are.
It's not as Keel that you pick up because you were read enough books or some
shit.
It's buyer.
Adobe is an extension of who you are and do you do it in a certain way so you
can design the perfect university,
the perfect college,
the perfect teaching environment.
The reality is it all boils down to WHO's in there,
why are the people there?
Because that's what makes all the difference no matter how you design it.
If you have the perfect set up with the wrong people,
it's not going to work.
That's his case with everything.
Right?
Yeah,
and it's always amazing to me like when you show up at a place and it's like one
place and they'll like a specialize in cheese and you go there and everyone's a
cheese expert and they're all like super knowledgeable and they're really nice
and friendly and it's like a small family business and all the pieces are in
place.
Like how is this even possible?
How can,
how can you get like this perfect environment even if it's just a small cheese
store and is it possible to get that on a grand scale like a university?
But that's why even the singles molar case is usually works during that first
generation with the energy of the people who put it in there,
who made the place amazing.
Rarely you're going to go with three generations down the road and the same
thing is going to be going on and that seems to be because they didn't have to
work for it.
Right.
It's sort of like us bio strategies that and partially is also who they are.
They probably they don't,
they are not as creative or they are not as funny or there's not as smart or
they are not as whatever and somebody else down the road is not going to be
because you're not going to have degeneration and after generations of perfect
people and is it's individual in that sense.
Yeah.
I've,
when I look at people and when I look at like the,
the,
the greater sort of a historical picture that we have of the human race and you
see all these like sort of peaks and valleys and peaks and valleys of
civilization and decline it,
it seems to me like it's really
hard for people to figure something out and then pass it on to other people with
the same impact as them figuring it out themselves.
So you have like all this,
all these accomplishments of the people that came before you would like running
water and electricity and,
but yet they're being enjoyed by people that don't even understand them a little
bit and really can't like,
can't appreciate the position of excellence and amazement that you really should
be in,
in this,
in,
in the,
in this 2012 arrows,
you know,
imagine if we are like in a post apocalyptic scenario,
somebody tried to is born after that and you have to explain what society now
was like.
It was like,
yeah,
you know,
we could talk into this microphone and there were like half a million people at
least in,
in across.
It's like how,
how,
what exactly.
No Way.
It's because the Internet,
I don't know,
assumption
what people don't understand is how easy that could happen.
And we could go right back to way the way things were just a few hundred years
ago.
That's a small,
small skip.
But it's easy.
It's really easy.
It's what we have is so fragile.
I think there,
cause you know,
they see something like Katrina and they sort of get a sense of it.
They see a sandy hurricane sandy and the weeks without power of,
I think opened up a lot of people's eyes at this.
This motherfucker's way more fragile than you think.
It's we,
we,
we have a very,
very fragile sort of thin veil of civilization
that we,
we live under the illusion of.
I mean even if you look at something as simple as oil,
which we base our old civilization on the routes,
on oil right now,
oil.
I mean,
we know that he's not going to last that long.
We don't know exactly how long.
It could be a sanctuary,
which case,
you know,
it doesn't affect us.
It could be who the hell knows.
But the bottom line is it's running out.
They will affect your grandchildren.
Yeah.
Big Time after he's gone.
But at the same time we haven't even gotten a good substitute.
And so it's like we're running on this honor society where right now it's,
it's on at that train,
you know?
Is that in somewhere where there's no,
unless somebody figure something out,
you know,
I think that,
yeah,
we actually had this discussion yesterday,
the idea of the race.
There's a race,
like the society is running out of resources and we're,
we're
living in this crazy sort of still this barbaric conquer or sort of a way,
uh,
stealing resources from other nations.
But at the same time,
technology and the connectedness of human beings is reaching like epic level
that has never reached before.
And it's what,
one of the reasons why it's making it so much more difficult to govern because
it's,
it's really hard to,
should people,
oh man,
I got a story for you.
This is going to be blew my mind the other day when I got these emails,
I was,
I'm speaking off your body's ability to connect with people on a greater scale
and all of that day are mentioning,
I got an email maybe four or five days ago,
um,
when the very beginning of days,
rarely Palestinian thing that just started.
I get these emails from this guy in Israel who tells me he just ran into a bomb
shelter and just hanging out there for the time being.
And he has,
he say,
you know,
I have enough food or enough water,
but uh,
what I'm doing to kill time in the meantime is Joe Rogan Experience Duncan
Trussell podcast and a and my and [inaudible] and my podcast.
And I was like,
fuck,
really are in a bunker in Israel with missiles flying and you're telling me that
that already blows my mind.
Now a day later or two days or something,
I got an email from some guy,
Palestinian guy who lives in France who tells me all about,
oh,
I like this thing you did that are,
and then she started getting about,
you know,
I'm really freaked out about my family in Gaza.
I'm super scared.
Uh,
and uh,
you know,
you might want to know that what I'm doing right now to be able to chill out a
second and not freak out about these things is,
and listening to you,
I'm listening to rogue and I'm restating to trust it.
I'm like,
you've gotta be fucking kidding me.
Right.
One Israeli guy,
one Palestinian guy basically telling me the exact same thing.
Whoa.
I see.
He didn't even know what to say.
You know,
he was,
Holy Shit.
Yeah,
that's exactly,
yeah.
With youthful societies,
uh,
in the,
in this day and age,
like the,
the youth of societies in this day and age,
they,
they have a perspective that really was never achievable before.
And they have,
uh,
an access to,
to things like podcasts and the Internet and websites.
And there's,
there's not as much difference between people's,
it used to be,
it's just not,
I mean,
in that way.
you know,
as far as like there's not,
it's hard to sell people on the idea of an enemy that you don't even know that
you never met.
And that's the beauty of globalization in a cultural level.
Economic level is the Fed that yet and nationalities and he's going to go down
or these bullshit stereotypes about the people from across any border will
become easier to know.
Real shit throw.
I made up facts that nobody got to test anyway cause you never got to see them.
Yeah.
It's funny how like everyone's scared of like the idea of the new world order.
You know,
everybody's scared of the idea of one global government.
Like I remember there was this big thing,
uh,
McCaffrey on a side,
his name on CNN was talking about,
uh,
the marrow that we're going to merge with Mexico and Canada and that's why
they're crashing the economy.
In order for us to come up with an a marrow and the way of one currency for the
entire region.
And like how,
how was that fucking you?
Any less than you're getting fucked now.
Like you're going to really trip out about that.
Like is if we had one world government would really be any less fair than it was
crazy government that we operate under.
You know what,
what would be different for Bradley manning the dude who released on wikileaks
documents?
If it's one world government,
would he still be in jail with no access to people or you know,
naked in a fucking cell?
What would be different?
Yeah,
it seems like one Tottenham obey would be the same with Guantanamo Bay.
Be the same.
If it was one world government,
I mean it was like if we really want to ourselves like
the,
the shining hope for civilization.
How do we have something like Guantanamo Bay?
How do we take these dudes and you know,
put blindfolds on him and fucking dog collar on behind their hands.
You know,
one other thing that cracks me up about,
well maybe could me up.
He's the wrong water enough.
They're mentioning one time about my buddy.
In any case,
the one of the things that's weird to me is I'll take an example of the United
States government people that are either flagwaving we are the greatest country
on earth kind of shit.
Or usually when they start finding out that no,
it's not all beautiful and you start finding out,
oh we just up in Tequila a few on there,
thousand Indians and his Labor bunch of people and uh,
you know,
set up a military coup in Chilean needle,
the sheet in Guatemala,
you know,
all of the ugly stuff of American history.
People flip and they were like,
the only evil in the world is the US government and everybody else who's against
it must be nice.
So if some crazy fundamentalist is nice,
no,
they're just misunderstood the real,
it's like,
fuck man,
it's not all black and white.
There's not that.
There's all that good guys,
bad guys stories.
He gets more complicated and that's why people are terrified of someone like
that American Taliban guy that decides the United States is evil and is going to
join the Taliban.
You know,
it's like people,
they have a very simplistic view of the world.
It's shaped by fiction and fiction is ruined many a mind to the complexities of
the actual real reality that we live in because most fiction is being
distributed in a way that I don't think that the human brain is designed to
process like the idea of movies that the human,
yeah,
human
body does not know what the fuck to do with movies.
And that's one of the reasons why they're so amazing to us.
When you go see something like Avatar and then you leave the theater and you
have avatar depression,
like that Shit's real.
Like people have avatar depression because they wished that life could be like
it is in Navea.
Wherever the fuck it is.
Where is it?
Navea yeah,
it guess what?
It's not even really Navea.
Okay.
You Fuck Navi as not real,
goddammit.
But it's,
we imitate our atmospheres were set up to do that.
You know,
if I live in a tribe and Danieli bull,
Ellie's there,
I want to listen to Danieli Bilali cause this is guys who has got the
information.
He's the head of the tribe that's follow him and he,
we can learn from him and it,
it allows us to learn things without having to fucking risk getting eaten by
boars ourselves.
Like we understand that we get the knowledge of that from you,
we,
and then we see things and we see things like some something happens to somebody
and it's a shocking thing and you learn from it.
You see drama and all these different various things that were set up.
We have like all these reward systems in our mind and our body in our,
in our,
on our human system that are set up to sort of interpret all these different
things that are happening in the world and place them in a way that allows you
to stay alive the longest to breed the most effectively.
But when you sit someone down in front of a movie screen,
all those and all
those brew award systems and all those,
all those different things that you have that have passed human beings from
generation to generation until they've gotten to this point.
All those things that are set up to reward you for certain things in the,
in the material world are being manipulated by giant HD screens and THX sound
and fucking perfectly written scripts and special effects and CGI and then you
know,
you really think that there's fucking good guys and bad guys out there.
You start,
you know thinking and this is America.
Okay.
And these colors don't ruin you start,
you start getting,
that's why I like mod there like the last decade or two of television because
he's changing the [inaudible].
You know,
you go from your traditional good guys,
bad guys story too.
Now you have,
you know,
shows like decks there where the hero is the serial killer or Brian or even
something like game of Thrones.
Yeah,
every bodies,
the good guys are awesome and they do horrendous things.
Okay,
I need the bed guys.
You hid their gods except that they do something really cool.
All of a sudden that throws you off and it's like,
that's more like life.
Much more like life.
I started watching homeland last night.
Is it pretty fucking good?
I had heard from a lot of people that it's really good.
They said,
dude,
that's like a movie every week.
It's like a really good movie every week.
And I heard from so many different people,
I was like,
okay,
I got to give this a shot.
So I watched the pilot last night.
It's fucking good.
That dude,
I don't know.
I should,
I should Google it because I don't know homeboy's name.
Uh,
whoever the guy is,
just the lead.
That guy was in a,
that Stephen King movie,
Dream Catcher,
really good movie for about three quarters of the movie and then fucking falls
apart all over itself.
Shit's all over itself.
But,
uh,
the guy who's the lead guy is,
the same dude.
What is his name?
And Damian Lewis,
he's one of those guys.
He's seen him in a million fucking movies,
a million TV shows,
but you don't know who the hell he is.
You know,
he's,
he's been in everything.
But that guy going to act as fucking ass off and it's a,
that other chick,
um,
what is her name?
Claire Danes who plays crazy very well.
It's pretty fucking good,
dude.
It's all good.
Show.
Just started it last night.
I've been addicted to the walking dead the lately.
Yeah.
Donkin can't stop talking about that shit.
It's not enough days in the world,
man.
Don't enough time to be sitting around watching all this amazing shit that
people are producing.
That was big enough TV.
But all of these is a pale,
you know,
it's,
it's tiny steps preparing you for the real shit.
The day when he in 2030 or whatever and and die.
We'll sit down to read the real corn the way it's supposed to be done for
television.
That would be the good day.
Yeah.
I think we're doing it now,
man.
I'm just doing this and doing,
I mean this is a like this,
this,
this forum,
the complete open free form,
like a real complete open free forum,
right?
This is what has been missing in our,
in our for a long
fucking time,
you could not get any mass mass distributed product,
whether it was a television show or radio show,
you really couldn't get anything that had as few rules as what podcasts have and
have the ease of distribution the way they have.
I mean like we were talking to my guy and Palestine and the guy in Israel and
he's listening to these podcasts in a,
in a bunker.
It's fucking crazy that this,
that didn't exist before.
There's no way for those guys to be exposed to all these,
uh,
different ideas and expose us to all these different ideas to just one of the
cooler things about what's,
um,
going on with this,
this experience of podcasting and social media.
It's for me personally is that it's very much a two way street.
Like I get a lot of uh,
feedback and a lot of information,
a lot of fuel from the people in social media,
like just from articles to read or interesting points that someone might have,
whether they disagreed with me or you know,
whether they had an alternative point of view that you might also want to
consider this.
Like a lot of fucking likeminded.
Cool,
interesting people are out.
No,
you bet man.
I actually,
without kissing your ass,
but I have to thank you to no end because ever seen being on your podcast the
first time and then jumping on Duncan's boat [inaudible] you really opened up my
word exactly to what you're saying.
Realizing that there are a bunch of people around the world who may be,
you know,
the weird freak of the lethal place or they leave where the doesn't mix with
everyone else.
But thanks to internet you can click and connect with the greater,
bigger word that it's awesome.
What put you in touch with,
do you know?
In many ways without sounding too flamboyantly really makes me feel better about
humanity.
Finding out that that stuff is out there.
So it's a,
I don't know,
man.
I think he's a,
it really blew my mind after being on your show the first time and then being
invited again and we're beginning to realize that there are other ways of
communicating beside the ones I'm familiar with and the effect that it has on
people,
the real effect,
you know,
real shit that people,
those are the best.
I'll show you when people try to staff net app and to them how they dealt with
or out something random that you saved in five minutes on a podcast effect that
somebody now strategy and that was a huge thing for their life.
And you're like,
is like the most humbling thing in the world.
You know,
it's really,
it's beautiful while we sit there at that impact on your life,
it just makes you thankful,
you know?
Oh,
100%.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm incredibly thankful,
you know?
And I'm thankful to you.
Uh,
if,
if it wasn't for people like you that I have these interesting conversations
with,
I wouldn't be able to do this either.
If it was just me by myself,
I would,
I repeat the same stories with guests.
Imagine leave and myself this podcast with suck,
you know I need need people to talk to and that's part of the beauty of having a
podcast is that it,
if you look at human consciousness as sort of a like almost like you know those,
the computer programs brains,
you know,
where you know what you,
you just have a thought and then
all these branches off of thought.
A lot of comedians use them to organize data,
organize jokes and,
and and segways and stuff like that.
If you look at the,
the,
the human consciousness as one big sort of brain,
what we've essentially done by having hundreds and hundreds of hours of this
sort of open minded,
sometimes silly but honest and,
and,
and the f friendly discussion is that you start this other branch and then boom,
these,
these things blossom off of his branch.
Whether it's a Duncan Trussell podcasts or the Joey Diaz podcasts or Tom Segura
is podcasts with his wife.
Christina,
what,
whatever it is,
your podcast,
these are these branches break off and form their own branches.
And then it,
and then it sort of attracts this group of people who get all this positive
energy from these discussions and all of this positive feedback,
this,
this residence,
you know,
that you get from,
from all these people that are,
that are really feeling like excitement and joy and enjoyment from these
discussions.
And it really does improve their life.
That and that it like creates like a whole,
it's almost like a sect of consciousness.
You know,
it's like we,
we,
we all know that what,
what we accept,
we all know that this is good for everybody.
We all know that there's a way to live life where you could be as friendly as
possible whenever you can.
And now it doesn't mean not calling people on their bullshit either.
Because by the way,
they need that.
And if someone calls you on your bullshit,
you should go take your fucking medicine.
Go,
you know what?
You're right.
I was a Douche there.
I fucked up.
I didn't mean to do that,
but it wasn't my intention.
That's,
uh,
that's one of the most interesting things about having a forum like that.
It's the,
the,
the ability to do that ability to create like some big just network of,
of human beings all connected to each other.
Yeah.
Which is,
I mean,
it really do.
You are literally throwing a rock and the reports effect.
You can't even begin to see them and when they do come back at you,
it's,
it's amazing.
It's really like the stories you get are like no fucking way really our
conversation in that particular day at that impact on,
it's weird man.
It's is really mind blowing.
Yeah.
It's totally unexpected to no,
that's the weird part about it is it sort of happened completely organically.
Just like this podcast happened completely organically.
I mean,
before this podcast I was just,
you know,
we were just doing stand up and I would write blogs a lot and you know,
and every now and then we would do,
uh,
we would do like a thing.
I think we did not Justin TV where we would,
uh,
put a laptop online and we'll,
I'll look through the web camera goes will boots,
you know,
it was really stupid,
but uh,
this sort of slowly but surely turned into what it is now.
And now when I do these shows and I meet all these people that say,
oh,
changed their life and you know this,
I'm like,
okay,
all right.
I don't,
I don't know how it happened.
I Dunno.
But I obviously have an obligation.
It's obviously a lot bigger than me.
Uh,
so I got to keep this,
keep this ball rolling.
But that's,
that's the way through because you know,
some people would see the exact same thing and feel like,
I'm like,
God damn,
I have that effect on people.
I am so cool.
They're silly bitches.
I try to,
first of all,
I tried to bring as many other people through,
like the way I described it as like we found a whole,
we found a hole in the fence,
right.
What I'm trying to do is bring as many cool people through the whole as
possible.
And that that's to me one of the most important aspects of,
of the position.
Like when you,
when you're in a position where people are paying attention,
they're paying attention to you,
you should point out some stuff that you've seen,
you know,
whether it's really good,
bands are really funny,
people are really interesting things.
So my,
my whole approach to it,
whether it's Twitter or anything,
is constantly pointing out the things that I find fascinating.
And then I find interesting and I mean even that,
speaking of changing lives,
how many doors do you open that way for somebody who maybe,
you know,
he's exactly what we're just,
could I be nerdy?
Somebody was awesome at what they,
they're do they work hard?
They are sensitive,
they need that.
But eiko flock one moment had opened one door that makes things happen for them.
Yeah.
That,
that's with me too,
with all of us.
We all need that.
We all benefit from,
from opportunities and it's super important to provide opportunities if they're
there.
If you see,
you know,
like if I see someone like yourself,
that's a fascinating,
interesting guy.
Like you,
people need to hear you talk.
Joey Diaz,
you know,
in any,
in any of these people that I bring myself around.
Um,
I think,
um,
this is,
uh,
it's,
it's a very strange time and,
uh,
there's not that many people that have that,
that ability.
There's not that many people that have that position.
No.
Sort of,
it's sort of like a Johnny Carson for the interview,
for the Internet.
You know what I mean?
Like Johnny Carson liquid introduce all these comedians to the world.
Yet when back in the day,
man,
if you've got on the Johnny Carson show,
it was fucking gigantic for your careers.
Did you ever hear like how he was like kind of a jerk to most comics?
Like if he didn't like you,
he wouldn't even look at you.
He went and I heard a lot of that.
Yeah.
But also I've heard that he was amazing too.
A lot of people too.
It makes me wonder like,
what would these people like that he was a jerk too.
I don't know.
You know,
I don't,
you know,
I,
I just used him as an example because he's,
he was always like the,
the guy who influenced,
uh,
comedians the most like help comedians and Rodney Dangerfield was another one
like Rodney Dangerfield.
What he did was he figured out that one of the best things that he could do with
all of his fame was to introduce the world to other comedians.
Right.
So that's how we found out about dice clay.
That's how we found out about Sam Kennison.
He,
Rodney Dangerfield was like the best at helping other people out and introducing
the world to all these other talented people.
And that goes back to what you are saying.
You know,
somebody may get Jellos Shit.
He's like,
you are gaining papa the IRD.
She is going to take it away from me.
You're a competitor.
I need to squash you.
And that's,
you know,
pretty solid stand.
It's defeat in India.
And I had those feelings,
especially when I was a younger man,
for sure.
I was jealous of a,
a lot of people that were better than me and things.
Uh,
it was just because it was dumb and I didn't understand what,
what would the sensation was in my mind and what the sensation was.
In my mind.
It was a,
it was a drive to be better and instead of being better,
I was trying to belittle the people who were better.
Right.
You know,
and it was just so,
cause that's a lot easier.
It was easier.
It was just,
it was an incorrect way of operating my mind.
Right?
That's all it was.
And the problem with that though is that you define yourself by the way you
operate your mind.
And that's how people get stuck in patterns so that you,
you define yourself by your past actions,
whether the in there,
if they're unfortunate and undesirable and embarrassing those things,
those things hurt you.
Right?
No big time.
And,
uh,
and I mean,
that's a thing.
Get raided and having to both just owning your mistakes,
you know,
big deal because everybody makes me steak,
everybody fuck up.
And that's the beauty because that's when you learn stuff rather than dealing
with deed.
Like Amen.
Whether I learned something from you or you learned something from me,
a wean.
Anyway,
you know,
he's like,
you lean more in a way when you fuck up because you're going to learn shit from
it and then you can move on and improve essentially as a human being.
People get stuck over the embarrassment or,
Ooh,
I messed up,
I need to hide it.
I need to squash it.
I need not to see it.
And he's like,
great.
Then you're going to have to wait 10 more times because you're not dealing with
it now.
Yeah.
Barring physical limitations,
like,
you know,
heart horrific injuries or whatever,
most of what you have in life that you go through that's very difficult is an
opportunity to grow.
You know?
And it's,
it's hard for people to wrap their heads around that,
but we all can do better.
And I'm not saying that every horrible thing that happens to you is,
uh,
is,
you know,
you should be happy for them.
No,
but you can turn it into something that,
that,
that motivates you and benefits you.
It's just really hard for people to do.
It's really hard for people to just put in the fucking work and it's hard.
It's hard to feel good about that.
You know,
it's hard to feel good about putting in the work and doing difficult shit.
But that's why to me it's funny because you'll get either the people who try to
rationalize every bad shit that happens in these old,
it's everything happens for a rezoning seeing the name and I just want to punch
them in the face cause he's like,
come on.
It's like really is like,
it's still about positive thinking.
Yeah.
Let me give you some pause it,
it's like,
come on,
my friend hits me with the Chili babies die and drive by dude.
They do exactly what happened.
The baby wasn't thinking positive.
There's some meaning.
There's no fucking meaning.
You know that.
So those guys piss me off.
But at the same time,
the depressive,
a cynical,
oh it's so bad and terrible.
There's no meaning in anything and go this shit.
He's like dead just as south defeatist if not more.
So to me it's like a knowledge that not everything makes sense and knowledge
that bad shit happens for no good reason to good people.
I knowledge that you'll deal with heartbreak,
tragedy,
fuck everybody dies.
It doesn't get any bigger than that and move on.
And you know this without necessarily saying that disease.
Uh,
it's because sandy Permian
is maybe because of nothing,
but what can I get from it now?
What can I learn from it?
Whether it happened for a good reason or a shitty reason,
where do I move from here?
Yeah,
that's uh,
one of the hardest things for people to wrap their heads around,
like an objective look at their situation.
A lot of people are really good at giving advice,
but they don't,
they couldn't give themselves advice.
Scars is that like the worst is when someone's an idiot and they want to give
you advice and you're like,
come on man,
stop it.
Manage your own fucking situation.
You dumb ass.
You know,
the,
the management of the human consciousness to me is one of the most important
things that a person needs to learn in life.
And one thing that they don't fucking teach you in school.
That is one of the craziest things about school is that they don't teach you how
to organize your mind and how to defeat negative thinking and how to encourage
positive thinking and build momentum with positive acts.
How to reinforce those positive things,
write things down that are doing well,
celebrate them with each other.
You know,
pass milestones.
Like there's a reason why like belts in martial arts like exist for thousands of
years.
You fucking feel good when you get a belt.
I remember when I got my blue belt,
I was on a fucking television show.
Okay.
And I didn't even,
the only thing I thought about being on the television show was like,
oh,
this is kind of cool.
I'm on TV.
It's great.
It's good money.
I feel very fortunate,
but it didn't give me the rush that I got when I caught a blue belt.
I was like,
Holy Shit,
I've got a blue belt in Jujitsu.
I'm not a white belt anymore.
You know?
It was like,
whoa.
I got out.
Fucking was beaming that day.
I went home.
I was all excited.
Wow,
I got my first belt.
Like this is awesome.
Like it was like a real positive feeling of,
of,
of moving forward.
That's something that you people,
people need a discipline man.
They need a little something to do.
Whether it's writing or whether it's you know,
a martial lard or fucking just become a marathon runner.
You need something where you push yourself so you can learn what you can do.
Yeah.
And literally can be anything cause he can be a physical discipline committee,
intellectual discipline,
maybe even both,
which would be ideal.
But yeah,
it's applying yourself to something because they're going to face the same
challenges.
So regardless of which specific field,
okay.
Maybe somebody is not going to punch you in the face when you are a painted or
something.
But the point being you're still going to be dealing with disappointment with
the learning Corp.
There's going to be
don't like your work and it's going to crush you.
And they might be right know they might be right or they might be haters.
You,
you know,
you find out a lot about life,
the dealing with people through your own discipline and people that are in
similar disciplines.
This is just a,
that that aspect of education is so,
so lacking.
It's so crazy when you really think about like engineering a society,
engineering the consciousness of a society,
which is what education is really supposed to be about really.
Essentially.
I mean you're,
you're,
uh,
making sure that the future generations are of contributing
and that's what you're doing.
And the funny thing is that that's usually,
there are exceptions,
but that's usually the last possible concern when it comes to academic
environments while the students actually learn is like student.
I mean,
I keyed in on,
I added people shit,
I remember a guy at Ucla once the data than me,
he had a tenure track job there and he was a professor and he was like,
you know,
this is a great gig if only I didn't have to teach because he was primarily
wanted to research and writing is stupid.
Econimic drawer and do is seeing a new dad and be a loner Weirdo.
Yeah.
And interacting with students bothered him and that actually less uretor than
you would imagine.
You know,
there's actually a lot of those guys were really comfortable in a pile of
documents in some more autocratic and they turn it okay,
action at bureaucracy,
which goes back to my fuck you and your mother fucking Mama because those are
the people who kill the fun of it,
you know?
But it's added all schools.
Is that at Harvard is at the highest levels of education?
Where do you find what,
like what school do you,
can you say,
should you not say where you teach at?
Yeah,
probably shouldn't say,
well,
I teach multiple places so it could be anyone that sending,
I got these shoes.
But honestly it's not even that personal now because they can't get in trouble
for no,
I mean it is your mother fucking Mama and I'll have it to be a big deal.
And you know,
what I meant to say is,
is a,
is the personnel in the sense that it could be them,
it could be somebody at they're faceless bureaucrat is a mentality.
You know what I mean?
He's not even like that single individual.
If he's not,
that is another one.
There's like,
so it's a lack of passion that disturbs you or lack of a pursuit of excellence
in upset or teaching and that you think is more common than not.
There's exceptional teachers,
but they're fairly rare.
Exactly.
And I mean,
you know,
even exceptions,
even a lot of exception if you guy like 20% of people who are good,
that's awesome.
That's actually good in a teaching environment,
which one you think about it,
you're relieving.
We teach people who kind of suck,
which is awful.
But even that I would sign up for that.
Well,
you know,
I'll you,
I think of it in terms of like people that are started out doing open mic nights
with how many of them have gone on and actually become professional comedians.
I only know out of all the people that I did it with three right?
And two of them,
I'm still friends with Chris Mcguire and Greg Fitzsimmons.
So those are two guys that I started out with.
It actually became professional comedians.
Right.
And that's a tiny number compared to the amount of people that we actually knew
from those days that we're attempting to do it.
So if you can get 20% of your students and those students become proficient in
whatever you're teaching,
whether you're teaching history or mathematics,
whatever,
that's pretty fucking good.
I'm set.
And the thing is,
thinking about the comedy example,
imagine that the people you started with,
there's no testing ground.
There is no people laugh or not think it's funny or not.
So your career is not shaped by actual feedback are good or not.
Your career is based on how well you stepped through the stupid academic hoops.
Like getting the jobs has nothing to do with actual teaching scale.
It's all about other crop that you research.
How good research I would go with your CV.
Luke's have you served in some subcommittee you where your span,
you know,
that kind of shit.
So it isn't that to encourage uh,
people to innovate and to keep coming up with new ideas and that the research is
how we learn things on the sciences,
sciences.
I dig it.
I see the point of it.
Even the,
in a lot of humanities,
social science,
the reality is that the so called the research is stuff written in indie stuff.
The academic language that the only other people are going to read are eight
other experts in the field that you might as well cold them right down and I
ride,
he's got up and he's the design almost to be missed.
Not something that's communicable to irregular audiences because of that makes
you look cool and learned and note of that.
And to me that's the exact opposite of communicational master.
You know,
communication mastery,
staking really difficult ideas and translating them in ways that anybody can
relate to.
Right?
Right.
Making them digestible so that any from any walk of life you can see a
connection to your life,
the easiest they can get the exact opposite direction he's making it.
We are then the pseudo intellectual game for nerds.
We walk into a library 40 years ago and never saw the light of the sun again.
You know,
is that those are,
cause that's the name assigning shut it,
it's,
it's really difficult to take advice from person who's not living a healthy
life.
Exactly.
And you can learn certain things from them but it should really be like the idea
of like the idea of the Samurai,
the Samurai had to be a well rounded person.
You gotta understand calligraphy and artwork and that having that one
well-rounded unit would serve you in battle because you would be a person of
character and clear thought of soda with it and that's what they do.
Occasional should be right,
but it's not that.
Definitely the percentage of teachers do you think are really innovating and
trying to provide a better learning environment and trying to like,
like you must have a bunch of professors that you are cool with
dark pool ladders.
There's a fairly high number of people who are nice human beings who meanwhile
there are bunch of obnoxious,
stuffy borrow crowds,
but there is a solid number of people lose made of Nice human beings.
They're just not very lunch human being.
So they're not bad.
They are,
they try it.
Just did or delivery,
durability to light.
Some turn a light on inside student side is very limited.
It's not because they are bad is I don't know whatever the fuck they are never
not be a,
it's almost like they're four months in that sense.
Is there any sort of a universal standard when it comes to Alexa getting a phd
in applied mathematics or in whether it's English or literature,
is there like a standard amongst all the universities in the country or does
each university sort of get together with its scholars and,
and sort of figure it out themselves?
This is what we think we should require of them in order for them to be,
uh,
you know,
to get a bachelor's degree.
This is everybody.
There are,
it's both.
There are certain general standards that are expected and then there are,
each school can push its policies in certain direction.
So they're both seeing success,
but they're usually not based on,
um,
on actual and what you're saying and making you a better human being.
That's not the goal of education is giving you a bunch of knowledge about stuff
you didn't know about which may be useful and some people will be able to take a
lot out of it and become and turn it into something that actually apply to life
or maybe use less crap that's invading your head for no good reason.
There is no connection to real life a lot of the time.
You know what I mean?
That's the biggest problem is he remains even when it's good.
It's a theoretical game that's not designed to change how you get up from the
seat and walk through class.
How you are as a human being,
how you feel is not designed to effect that is purely about knowledge for
knowledge sake,
which you know,
it has some good sides,
but it also some major limits right there
to so many fucking things to know and learn.
If you're just just learning grammar,
language,
education,
logic,
mathematics,
who you start going over the various disciplines and do various things that a
person can,
there's not enough time in your young life to really put together a,
an an accurate piece of the world and then go out and be a part of it.
Right.
It's,
that's the weirdest thing about school is that when Mo,
most of my friends that graduated cause like right when they got out,
that was like one of the weirdest times in their life where they were like,
fuck,
now what?
You know,
now what do I bad fucking been buried in books for all these years and trying to
figure and now I'm out there like,
oh,
key dokie.
Like here,
here goes,
here goes nothing.
It's almost like,
uh,
it's,
it's real hard to get a realistic view of the world before you were an adult,
right?
Yeah.
I mean before you'll got actual experience,
you know what I mean?
Doing stuff right there and then being stuck in his intellectual game.
And I mean I'm a nerd,
you know,
I love to read like crazy.
I love to know sings about a million different subject.
So I'm fire from advocate,
dean,
anti intellectualism,
fire from it,
but at the same time to me for real intellect goes hand in hand with a certain
relationship with your body.
We Test Sarah Camera.
It's about,
it's about bullets,
you know what I mean?
It makes you,
makes you a more complete human being.
It makes you better at not only,
you know,
if you are an athlete and they are smart,
probably going to be a better,
I thought latex not only at the other stuff,
as long as you don't have too much homework.
That's what I show the fuck up your training.
If you know,
if you're a nerd and you know we live in this idea that your thoughts are,
you know,
y'all are really these gnome that stuck in your head that's directing the
machine of the body so that who you are physically doesn't really affect your
consciousness,
which is essentially what's cool is that here,
right?
Because I mean look at how people learn.
You go sit into these really uncomfortable chairs facing forward.
Your body wants to stretch you on a movie,
on a Shiksa manage.
You can't,
you're supposed to stay there.
The Easton Easton to some bastard up there,
it was going blah,
blah blah.
Integrating more consciousness affecting conscious any,
it's so avid ceilings that are about giving it a lot more importance to the
body,
to physical experiences.
Not All [inaudible] two hours of pee somewhere,
which is,
it's not about consciousness,
it's about moving muscle and shit,
which is nice,
but it's not.
The same thing is also emphasizing our,
through a whole variety of physical discipline,
you can affect the mind.
You can affect speed eight if you want to get that fire,
you can.
There's a connection between all these different things.
Whereas we have this mentality that all knowledge is about knowledge sake.
There's a relatively really no connection to your body and a vetted the telco
room to actually applying that knowledge in real life,
which to me is missing the point because he's like,
if knowledge is not,
if it doesn't make,
if it doesn't improve the quality of your life,
what the Hell is the point?
You know?
And uh,
it,
it doesn't,
I don't mean just,
Oh it needs to make the car on the road or some stuff.
He could be even intellectually but over the quality of your life.
Cause it makes you happy because it makes you relate better to another human
being's well that has an effect in life.
Well,
I'm talking about knowledge that just about in the year 1763 [inaudible] and
there is no time to lean kit,
which why,
what's the point?
What's the lesson you can learn?
What can you get out of it for your life?
There is no effort whatsoever and never doubted
is it because it's just too much information to give people,
they don't have time for that aspect of it.
Part of it for sure.
Because there's a bunch of factual things you need to get and they are less
controversial,
you know,
there's no argument about a factual stuff.
Whereas when you're a supporting quote trying to educate somebody,
there's also an element of who are you?
Are you are human being okay as something to offer to somebody else or use some
guy in a position of power who's trying to force this on more subjective thing
on people.
So what you're telling me is academics
and uh,
academia in general just needs more mushrooms.
That's ward by ward.
What I was saying,
that's what I seismic I'm hearing they need a fresh perspective and a
psychedelic outlook.
Yeah.
I think I'm gonna have a mushroom Thanksgiving this year.
It's a good move.
Do it.
If I wasn't with my kids,
I would do it.
I mean San Diego,
I said I might stay an extra day.
Holla.
Don't say that man.
They'll find you in San Diego.
They've got a mushroom sniffing dog.
It's right near the fucking military base.
The last thing they want is mushrooms in the military.
That is the last thing you need.
And you're in the military is mushrooms.
You need amphetamines and steroids.
You don't need mushrooms.
Right.
Okay.
You were out there.
You want to come home safe.
Mushrooms are for later.
Rooms are for when you get back.
Uh,
I,
I've talked to a lot of dudes who are in Afghanistan who listened to the podcast
over there,
a lot of troops listening to podcasts over there.
And,
uh,
it's a,
it's a weird conversation.
You know,
I've had a bunch of them with dudes after
shows.
I go,
listen man,
you,
you know,
you don't even know,
but you guys kept me sane when I,
when I was over there.
That's a,
another strange responsibility for people that are,
uh,
you know,
in,
in such a tough position to be a over at war and to be providing them with some
other thoughts.
So listen,
amphetamines and steroids and keep pulling that trigger and run.
You didn't create the shit.
He just stuck in it.
It's like the running man.
Just get through it before the aliens land.
Do you,
um,
what,
what do you think about all these ancient aliens,
motherfuckers that want to say that?
Uh,
the original,
uh,
sources of humanity was that we were created by aliens.
Does that seem ridiculous to you?
I mean,
sure it does,
but at the same time,
just because he's there,
they,
it doesn't mean it can be through.
We exist.
Yeah.
There was a Harvard guy,
some astronomer who was talking about the likelihood of life in the universe is
very small.
Right.
It's very likely that we are alone because they searched for 504 search,
500 different planets and they found no signs of life.
I thought that was the dumbest thing I've ever heard out of a smart guys mouth
because this 500 he said he found firing and they found nothing.
No.
Yo,
you search 501 dummy.
Right?
Because earth is one of them and earth has life.
Yeah,
so you found one which is fucking crazy.
We are crazy.
The fact that we exist at all and that we have internet and then we have Google
on our phone and then we can fly in tubes.
The hope that fucking shoot,
you're 30,000 feet in the air.
That's what I'm saying on son.
He mentioned this.
Could I be get to somebody who doesn't know anything about it is I say it sound
like alien tails.
Well I always used to talk about it on stage that you tried to rap.
Try wrapping your head around the fact that 200 years ago,
if you wanted a picture of something,
you had to draw it like that is not that long ago.
Or even,
yeah,
around that time is like forget playing any music.
The only music you ever had a year of his life and it was a can.
There's nothing else cause you can,
you know,
there's no recording device that you can press,
play and go,
yeah,
now I have gigs of music on my phone.
Yeah.
You know,
it just,
it never fails to trip me out that I can go to my foot.
Like I don't have an iPod anymore.
I mean I have an Ipod,
um,
uh,
the one of like,
oh,
I have a,
like a leftover one,
but your phone becomes also your eye.
But when I go to the gym,
I play my phone and there's so much variety in there.
There's thousands of fucking songs.
And your phone best music.
I've seen the word old talk inside your phone.
We can't even wrap our stupid heads around it.
It's like what I was saying about the rise and fall of these civilizations like
we we're experiencing and we're benefiting from something we don't even
understand a little bit.
Whereas when you were living in the pioneer days,
everything was pretty straight forward.
You had a fix that wagon wheel and this is what you gotta do.
You gotta take,
some would pound the metal and do this and then put the wheel back on.
And if you want to,
you know,
shoot a deer,
you got to sneak up on it.
And this is how you skin it and they say cut it into and if it's fucking hot
out,
you better smoke.
That shit.
Turned it to beef jerky.
Otherwise it'll go bad.
Like we knew how to manage all of the things that we had in our environment.
And if we didn't,
we knew a guy in town who did,
well,
I'm not a blacksmith,
but Bob is,
and I'll go to Bob and get some more shoes.
You know,
like I remember that movie,
the unforgiven,
the cleanings would move him seeing him like out on the farm with his fucking
kids.
Like,
like trying to,
trying to farm and fallen flat on his face,
trying to push pigs into a pen.
That's,
that was reality for everybody.
That was the only way to live.
That's,
that's all that existed.
And you knew how to manage all the different aspects of your life.
You understood how a gun worked.
You understood how to sharpen an ax.
Not Anymore,
man.
I'm fucking pressing buttons.
I don't even understand.
I have never even thought about trying to understand wireless Internet,
but I'm on it right now.
I know.
I've never even thought about attempting for a moment to gain any sort of an
understanding of it.
I mean,
that's so much of disease.
So beyond anything you can get quickly or under,
cause he would have to understand so much of physics so much.
It's,
it's like forget it.
Okay.
It works.
I press play.
Works on happy.
Yeah.
We're civilization spoiled.
Do you think that that's just a stage though?
And that one day our brains would catch up with all this shit and like they say
the human brain doubled in size over a period of 2 million years.
So at some point in human evolution,
that's what separated us.
We,
that's how we took her off from the other apes.
Is that,
is that going on right now?
I mean probably cause I mean when you look
good,
the speed of technological innovation off nonetheless thousand years,
the last hundred,
you know when you can see there maybe 150,
a like three CT phones,
cars or planes,
TV,
radio,
computer,
Inter.
It's like all of it is,
it's mind blowing really.
Cause it's all in the span of just very few.
I mean fuck,
I remember when I was a kid in Italy and I'm not like these old guy who was
like,
you know,
back in my time or no,
I mean,
um,
late thirties.
And I remember when I was a kid that if I wanted to find out what the MBA
finals,
I would call the one Italian magazine,
the cover basketball day at talk to their friend in New York who had given them
the news.
And so maybe two days later when they open for business,
I get to find out who won the NBA final.
If I don't make that call,
I have to wait a month for the magazine to be published so I know who won the
game.
And I'm like,
that was what,
25 years ago or something 30 years ago.
Are you kidding me?
I mean now you can be in some hole in the wall somewhere,
you have Internet connection and you can watch it live and it's insane.
You know it,
it really is
and it's changing now.
It's getting crazier and crazier and it's not going to stop.
And this,
this what we have now,
so amazing,
but it really is the tip of the iceberg and one of the side effects is going to
be a complete and total lack of privacy that's on the side effects that people
have to understand.
Sure.
Like you enjoy your privacy while you can,
right.
Because eventually it's not gonna exist.
We are slowly,
uh,
married,
immersing ourselves in the,
the,
the mass of humanity as like one super organism.
Yup.
That's,
that's really where it's all going and it's going,
the,
all the boundaries are going to go away through technology and then technology
eventually,
biologically will be a part of our system.
So we'll,
we'll,
we'll have some chips inside of our body or we'll have some implants that we,
uh,
install into people's bodies and that quick and easy way.
And for people that,
that d that say that all,
that's crazy sign,
that's not going to happen.
Look at Pamela Anderson's tits.
Okay.
Look at what she's accepted.
She has accepted bags of water under her nipples that make her tits pop out in
an unrealistic way.
You don't think that you're going to accept a chip in your brain.
It's going to let you see the future.
That's ridiculous.
You're going to take it.
You're going to get that operation.
There's going to be dudes who were stupid as fuck and there's going to be dudes
with brain jobs and those do the w brain jobs.
There'll be running shit.
They'll be fucking flying around in private jets and Ferrari's and you're like,
it don't need a bit fucking super moon live in the country and these colors
don't run and you're out there chopping wood with an ax.
You fucking dummy and this guy could read your mind.
Okay,
this guy's got a fucking little piece of silicone on the base of his skull and
he could see through walls.
Right?
You're not going to take that.
You're dumb.
You're dumb dumb.
You're going to,
you're going to be back there with the monkeys who couldn't figure out how to
make fire,
right?
Yeah.
All those stupid fucks.
There's still an Africa swinging from trees that's used to be us apparently
millions of years ago supposedly.
Have you seen that new shit where they found that,
uh,
people were,
um,
that human beings 500,000 years ago were using tools and using m Flint,
Flint tipped,
spears and arrows.
Most,
the most recent,
uh,
discovery,
which predates what we thought human beings used as tools.
Uh,
by 200,000 years,
let's see.
Insane.
I mean saying,
I don't even know what human beings 500,000 years ago would have looked like as
were talking about.
No shit
man.
I wonder what they looked like,
I bet.
Yeah.
What I mean,
how eight,
like where are we,
you know,
a half a million years ago?
When did it,
well,
they know that neanderthals,
notice how I said talls like a true intellectual with my three years of college.
Um,
they know that they,
uh,
they,
they made,
um,
they've done not only made weapons,
but they also,
uh,
were navigators.
They're one of the most recent discoveries is that they think they flew,
they sailed out to islands on their own,
you know,
without a homo sapiens.
And neanderthals had figured out how to make boats.
This is,
they didn't really think that just to a few decades ago.
They were around until relatively speaking now that long ago because they went
extinct like maybe 30,000 years ago or something.
And they went around since maybe two and their cubs in two years ago that that
lot times shared by Homo sapiens sapiens and the neon their tele at the same
time.
It's,
yeah,
that's nuts man.
Huh.
That's uh,
the,
they were weird looking dude.
They were like five feet tall,
200 pounds solid rock walkie talkie is fuck.
They all looked like who some are Paul Harris x but not,
but not with that head.
Like he has a human hat.
They had like weird heads.
They are like crazy for foreheads heavy.
Yeah.
I saw a documentary where they were um,
trying to uh,
put like a,
like clay and like reconstruct a neanderthals face and they compare it to a
human being.
He had a homosapien right next to the article.
There's so many prominent features are different.
The brow and the like,
they were a totally different fucking thing,
but they were real close,
real close to us.
They had,
they,
um,
they crossed the Mediterranean in boats a hundred thousand years ago.
Isn't that amazing?
They were,
some people still think they were swimmers by the way,
but there's other people that are saying they found they have found distinctive,
uh,
like uh,
evidence that they had made it to these islands.
Yeah.
There's no just that's insane.
Maybe the gun as well.
Well let me get with crocodiles.
Yeah,
right.
You'll months can sweep,
but the,
no,
that's fakey and Nan there does where actually the first one way to burry their
bodies.
So they are the first species that have a burial for their dad before
homosapiens down as far as,
well,
cause I mean a lot of Homo sapiens sees a lot of the evidence that we have.
Typically what we could,
like the staff pass the hand there thousand years ago,
we really don't know a whole lot about,
you know what I mean?
There's like you find a fragment of a tooth from 300,000 years and then you find
the they'll finger from,
it's like so poutine together.
There's a lot of guesswork involved about this stuff.
And that's part of what's fun about it is that every other day there's new
articles coming in.
We can,
you know,
theories that make it,
uh,
the change there is like the stuff that we thought we knew until yesterday.
Scratch that.
That was bullshit.
We actually now know that what you just said like you know,
500 years ago,
there would a 500,000 years ago they used on tools,
whereas before we thought a lot less that staff is constantly changing.
My,
one of the theories have been tilled as far as I know,
still current was that,
and then there are times where the first two,
uh,
to burry their dead,
which is a three p itself that some known human species or letter related to us,
but not us,
could do the exact same thing.
Would it be crazy if humans learned how to see fair from neanderthals if homo
sapiens humans cause they,
they actually work humans,
I'm saying it wrong,
but they did it before us supposedly.
Right.
But then there's other people that think that we have absorbed them.
You know,
in a,
in this,
this two different schools of thought on that.
One of them is that we interbred with them and one of his,
and no,
we just shared DNA from the get go and it's just,
we're better at understanding that now.
Yeah.
They say that basically now I'm,
they're adults in order to evolutionary dead end that there is no crossover with
human beings is only ancestral stuff or,
exactly.
Or instead a hat be Nando tell sex scenario where homosapien sapiens and now in
their lab sites and dudes,
fuck dudes.
They would definitely fucking the Anatol check the old up to if they could get
some,
if they're in the middle of nowhere.
If you like hunting elk with a stick and you find some hot Niana tall chick and
she's ready to go,
you're like,
all right,
come on,
let's do it on.
It's on.
Yeah,
man.
Shit done.
I've traveled before and crows come through where we are on the road for days on
end and after a while from state after state,
you see the average woman be 300 pounds.
When suddenly you see at and their pound woman,
you're like,
oh my God,
that's so hot.
You know,
so it's just,
it's sold that I left.
If you make an adjustment,
you have yourself a Harem of neanderthal chicks then make you big,
thick,
baby's too big,
strong ones.
Hundred thousand years ago,
these guys were taking boats as far as a 12 kilometers.
That's pretty incredible.
That's really incredible.
Well actually some of them even 40 kilometers,
some of them made me even more ambitious journeys.
That sounds amazing.
I man,
that's why.
How the fuck did homosapiens just occur?
I mean not,
it's not like it just occurred,
but if you really stop and look at us,
right,
the fleshy weak ass bitches,
but very,
very clever and compare us to all the other apes is what a weird sort of a
journey to go from whatever the fuck it,
I mean,
I don't understand how the creation of species,
I understand the evolution,
what's the species has been established for the most part of it,
with what currently understood about that.
I've sort of tried to wrap my head around that,
but I don't understand the emergence.
Like on our side,
it has a frog just become a frog.
How does that bird who were,
where does an eagle come from?
You know,
like,
was there some steps along the way?
I'm sure there were.
The problem with the fossil record though,
it's that there's not enough evidence left behind to really piece and accurate.
Most Shit doesn't become a fossil.
No.
People that like,
people that have never really thought about it don't understand how difficult it
is to make a fossil.
Like you have to have some sort of a cataclysmic situation where a volcano or a
mud slide or something traps the people,
um,
like,
uh,
amber SAP can trap million year old bugs and we learned a lot from that.
Um,
but most people,
the your,
your nature just absorbs us.
Most animals nature absorbs them.
It's like you leave a bear,
a dead bear in the woods.
Like you come back in a month later,
there's nothing left.
No,
I mean,
that's fine.
In fact,
these three books are always the thick as the,
you know,
you go through the first 200,000 years of feast,
they're like two pages,
then you go in the last 10 years there were like three books.
Fake of it is not because he's any more interesting is because we know more.
You know,
that's what it boils down to.
I listened to this lecture once,
um,
I think it was,
I think it was another Mckenna one where he was talking about if you had a
computer have sufficient power and you understood when variables and you
understood you could,
you could program the,
all the measurements from a sand dune and from that sand Dune,
you could get a map of the wind and you could,
you could literally get an accurate representation of how fast the wind was
blowing and for how long and how did it create this from the,
this mass of sand.
And I always wondered like,
I wonder if what just what we can do now is so bizarre as far as exchange data
and as far as figure things out and communication,
uh,
wonder if it's possible to take the results of life on this planet in what we
know of over the last,
you know,
2030,
whatever it is,
a hundred years of accurate history and put what we know to be 100% true in some
sort of a gigantic mathematical program and extrapolate the past from that or
eh,
or make a calculation from what we know and literally be able to get an accurate
representation of everything from single celled organisms to dinosaurs all the
way to a human being and recreate that in a way that people could actually
watch.
That could be the kind of thing that 300 years from now standard we look now
like really does bustards didn't know about that.
Of course he could do that.
Stupid.
Yeah.
Well they'll probably laugh at people with like a sex change too,
right?
Like are you got to go and get your Dick cut off?
Dude,
why don't you just go into the sex change center,
press the button.
I want to be a black woman.
Hold on the new like a fucking,
like a,
like,
like fixing a hot pocket
one day.
That's if we can,
if we can make people look like women,
we are going to be able to make you a woman one day,
you know?
Alright.
Unquestionably,
there's,
there's going to be some unbelievable manipulation of reality coming up in the
future.
Before that,
I'm imagining,
can you picture when they finally figured out,
very rarely stick robots that look like humans and everybody can buy like the
hottest possible sex power nurse on the planet for like 500 bucks at target.
And,
uh,
people will never leave the house.
You know what I mean?
Is a society as we know,
it will come to an end once that sex toys will be perfect at it because no one
will leave the damn hours if you have in your closet 10 of the hottest women or
men or whatever
fucking party
fucking party.
And they will,
uh,
you know,
it's not even gave,
they're not real robot.
You Fuck robot that day.
But look,
you're willing to fuck a flashlight,
but you're not willing to fuck a robot.
Dude.
What if someone made you a robot dude with the perfect vagina?
Everything else you know you had except the fact that it looked like a dude,
but God vagina.
Perfect.
No,
you wouldn't do it,
but you would fuck a fleshlight as long as you can contain it into a nonhuman
tube.
Exactly.
That's it.
Looked a guy for so
strange.
We had a dude on the other day who's a robotics expert.
Uh,
Daniel H.
Wilson.
Fascinating guy.
Great conversation.
It was really easy.
He freaked me the fuck out,
man.
There's,
we're talking about like,
when's the first guy gonna cut his legs off and put robot legs on?
It.
Really,
it really made me cringe when he said it.
Cause I was like,
he's right.
And that's going to happen.
Like there's gonna come a point in time.
We were talking about a amputees who never run in the Olympics with special
prosthetics.
And that one day they're going to have legs that are better than a human.
You're going to laugh at human legs,
so they're going to have some fucking awesome,
like they came up with some artificial skin cell that was a,
it was an,
it was mixed with steel.
I,
I got to understand how the fuck they did that.
Let me,
uh,
let me,
let me Google this real quick,
but it's the beginning.
It's an artificial human cell with somehow another fucking steel fibers woven
into it.
Yeah.
It's,
I dunno,
I dunno what the fuck they did.
I don't,
I don't totally understand it,
but they're,
they're able to create artificial cells now and they're,
it's not all like,
it's not all with like,
uh,
like flesh.
Like they can,
they can do it with like varying materials.
Like they think they're going to be able to create skin,
um,
based on spider silk or spider webs that's bulletproof.
No Way.
Yeah.
That in the future they will be able to replace human skin with a bulletproof
substitute.
No,
come on.
You're making,
no,
I'm not.
Yeah,
absolutely serious.
They're,
they're trying to mean they've,
they've already figured out a way to make certain animals produce spider silk.
Is that Jeff facts?
One day we'll have it.
Well,
I don't think,
I think like Jeff,
the problem at jetpacks is like they would have to be like all magnetized so
that you couldn't crash into each other.
Like you get really close like two magnets and Whoa.
Yeah.
You fly on the flying cars.
That's why one of the reasons why helicopters never took off.
When they first made the helicopter,
they thought that it was going to replace the car.
That was the idea.
But then they realized it's people are too fucking stupid for that right now.
Yeah.
There was a big helicopter crash in Manhattan.
That's a billionaire guy died and turns out he had his five year old daughter in
his lap and she was kicking the controls.
Oh,
you got to make it.
No,
she kicked it.
Controls the helicopter went into a fucking tailspin and they died.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Whoops.
That's why helicopters can't replace cars.
No,
I mean,
shit,
it's Amena Code already when you're driving on the freeway and you look at all
the people driving either really,
we're not crushing into each other every cycle and know that it amazes me,
especially when you go and you see what fucking people put on their Twitter page
and then you go,
how is this ape staying in my lane?
It fucking dumb.
Dumb.
Yeah.
Is that the product of the education system or is it,
there's a broad spectrum of the human mind and there's some people that are,
they're born ditch diggers.
I'll show them be definitely optional.
Goddammit.
This is coming from an educator,
ladies and gentlemen,
a very smart guy thinks there's ditch diggers.
Fuck.
I was hoping for for the best.
Is there a way like we can give them that?
What does that stuff,
uh,
from the limitless movie,
what was that Nzt that you,
you give people and they fucking become super smart.
He was like a lazy bitch.
And then he wrote a book in like a day and became a billionaire.
Kind of like the matrix support approach to learning where you plug in the thing
and you're like,
I know cofo.
Yeah,
exactly.
What little,
you know the brain chip that we were talking about earlier,
the guy gets a brain job.
Maybe that's going to save all the ditch diggers and then we'll just make robots
to ditch dicks,
dicks,
and six with our,
maybe I'm thinking about dicks.
Very Dick Oriented show.
So happy to,
well,
you've contributed to it,
sir.
You're here.
You're responsible to,
it's a fucking group environment.
Sorry,
go ahead.
Were you gonna say
you stop for say folks,
there is evolution everywhere.
Even here on the podcast grind,
red ban is catching himself
hog
for,
no,
it's not a call for.
That's a good thing.
Then I said it was uncaught won't welcome to everybody's life.
Everybody in fall for this podcast has benefited from saying things were
uncalled for it,
you know,
I think the world could use a little more uncalled for.
Shit.
All right.
God dammit.
Everybody's,
everybody wants everything to be beautiful and perfect and called for right
sometimes.
No,
there's hiccups.
We're figuring this thing out as we move along.
Folks.
No one,
uh,
no one's got it down to a science.
None of those Buddhist monks even get laid.
Okay?
That's how you know the Buddhists are wrong.
They're wrong to everybody's wrong.
You know why they're wrong.
No Pussy.
That's several simple.
Have you ever had sex?
Yes.
Isn't it awesome?
Yes,
it is.
They're not having something awesome.
If you live your life and you don't experience something,
that's one of the best things that you can experience a year are missing out on
one of the best parts about this life.
And the idea is,
well,
it consumes you and you want to be free from that.
I don't have this and stop being a silly bitch.
Stop being silly,
bitch.
It doesn't have to consume you.
That's like someone who's a,
you know,
uh,
an alcoholic saying that no one should enjoy wine.
Right?
Well,
that's not true because some people can have wine and then they get laughing and
have a great conversation.
I have sex with someone they probably wouldn't have sex with.
And next thing you know,
oh,
jet's a millionaire.
It's not the wrong with wine folks.
And that to me is like the litmus test of a healthy religion is their attitudes
about sex at warming.
Guys,
he's like,
but even that,
there's some really weird,
I would join the Mormons before I would join any other religion,
especially old school ones.
It had eight wives block it.
I would go down to Mexico and join up with the Mitt Romney's clan,
take up guns against the cartels.
The least they had a bunch of wives.
I mean it seems like no one can figure out the whole monogamy thing that you
look at the divorce rate in America,
I think it's 51% right?
And uh,
for primates it's zero.
It's zero.
Monogamous primates,
yes.
Zero.
No mean we're the only ones who pull it together.
We keep it together.
We'll keep it,
give it a flick.
And you know,
you keep it going for a hundred years,
then you'd die.
But if people live to like be infinity,
how might your wet,
once ray Kurzweil's ideas come to light and we have endless existences,
what will we,
well,
you know what in the back then we'll have,
but by the time we get to that point,
I bet we'll have,
uh,
some sort of an artificial reality anyway that people would be enjoying more
than regular reality anyway.
Yeah.
Because there'll be some world of Warcraft shit that you can plug your brain
into.
Yeah.
The Matrix is real.
Did you ever fall simulation theory following fallen into these wacky
motherfuckers know scary shit,
man.
Yeah.
Cause it's based on mathematics.
They're finding,
well,
I'll,
I'll Google it because I don't really understand it,
but,
uh,
they're finding these mathematical equations inside string theory and they're a
self correcting and it's freaking people out because,
uh,
they're very,
I don't want me to pull this up here.
So correcting.
Yeah,
they're,
um,
they're finding this,
uh,
type of,
um,
self correcting computer code that they've,
uh,
they've,
they've known about since I believe it was like the 1940s.
And they're starting to find this in the equations of string theory.
It's very,
it's really fucking confusing because you don't understand.
Do you understand mathematics?
Like do you understand what they're talking about when they say the equations of
string theory?
Fuck no,
no idea.
I mean Matt Dummies,
one of the mysteries of the universe.
Universities.
No,
I'll go out to add in my head to subtract to do stuff that I actually use.
Anything else.
And that's it.
I think you either have it or you down.
I think that's like a part of your brain that's your active or not
because you think it's a nurture thing from childhood that like you,
you like some people get stimulated as a child and they start pursuing that road
and then it becomes a part of their natural existence and then it becomes
normal.
I think it's your,
how your brain thinks.
Like if you're a certain way,
a thought pattern,
it,
you're not,
you don't,
you don't get it as easy as somebody that's more number driven.
Like architects,
like architects a,
if you look at an architect,
most of them understand all this complex,
crazy shit,
but then you try to talk to him and it was just the most right one sided that
they only understand architecture kind of thing.
I don't know.
Yeah,
maybe.
Well,
I,
I certainly think if you,
if you look at the human race as being like one big crazy giant organism,
you would think that everybody would have a part in it in order for it to,
to keep progressing and then it wouldn't really work the right way if everybody
was the same,
right?
If everybody was the same,
there really wouldn't be that much in innovation and nothing would get done.
So it almost makes sense that you're going to have,
you know,
mathematical prodigies that can't run
fast,
you know,
and then you're going to have dudes who are,
are really awesome at a space and distance and eye hand coordination,
but they just suck at putting numbers together or they suck at driving or you
know,
whatever.
That's not a good example.
But you know,
it seems like if you,
if you accept the fact that human beings,
so the only way we work is we work together.
That's the only way.
I mean you,
if you're a loner,
if you're one of those Ted Kaczynski guys live in the woods drinking your own
piss,
nobody trusts you.
Okay.
You know what,
why would I trust some guy who was up there a on the mountain top and it never
comes down and talks to people.
We,
we,
if we accept that we all are without question,
need each other,
then you kind of think that it's got a sort of how it must have some sort of
formula to it,
you know,
which is why like I always felt like if things got bad,
things got overpopulated or things got crazy,
like there's always going to be like disease.
There's going to be some spring back.
It's always going to be something that tries to stop it.
I mean,
of course does the less growth doesn't exist in nature.
You know what I mean?
It's just you can,
you can only heat go on for so long before eventually you hit your limits and
you come crushing down and just not gonna.
Uh,
you know,
there's no animal species ever that can outstrip the,
it's the resources.
It just doesn't work right.
Because you run out of shit and we are smart so we can keep come up like pushing
the limits because we have a new technological innovation that allows us to get
more out of less space and all of that.
So we've played a game well,
but I mean you can only play it so long before eventually you don't come up with
something.
But he landed in the next a hundred years and then you're fucked.
Yeah.
And when you look at how many people there are and how many people that used to
be,
yeah,
that's crazy.
And Sunday we've grown so quick.
It's not that look like we had doctor Peter Duesberg on who was the HIV guys
says HIV doesn't cause he was talking about the population in Africa tripling
the population's tripled over the past like 20 or 30 years.
Right.
Fuck it's been,
did they started measuring?
It should not even that long ago.
If you think like,
um,
something like the entire population of the United States in the year 8,900,
so two and they're barely over 200 years was a about 5 million people.
It's not even all of her late today.
You know what I mean?
Is like less than the entire population.
That was the whole population of us.
Less than a late today.
Hey Brian,
this is loud as fuck.
What are you doing man?
What's going on out there?
30 Asian women.
Oh,
you son of a bitch.
Have a seat.
They're all just hanging out right next to the studio for some reason.
Is that what you were going to check on the noise?
Yeah.
What the hell are these people?
But there's like a seriously like 38 and I'm going to check on the noise.
We've got an issue here behind you.
Check on the noise.
Um,
the,
that allowed us fuck someone.
Go stick a dick in her mouth.
Right?
And quickly
stop all that giggling.
Brian,
it's your duty for all these podcasts.
People.
What were we even talking about before we got to interrupted?
Besides computer theories and self correct purse.
Oh,
population population went from zero to 5 million.
Is that what you said?
200 years ago.
Early on in the year 1800 fucking a that's insane.
That's a lot though.
If you really stop and think about it,
that's incredible.
They come over on boats and horses at 5 million of them,
but that's after two and 30 hours of colonizations and you know when she started
the very beginning you're really talking about,
you know,
so few people.
It is,
I don't know man.
He said one of the single verb population is one of the things that nobody wants
to talk about because he's uncomfortable cause what are you gonna do?
Tell people they can't have,
how many kids they want.
That's not a very nice seemed to do.
And at the same time you kind of have to at some point because you can't
possibly keep it going forever.
And eugenics is a really horrible subject.
You can,
you can never bring that up.
We never bring the idea up that you need to call the population even though
that's like a natural part of nature.
I said the strong survive because I mean the whole Chinese model off if you have
more than one kid will bash on the hat is effective,
but it's not exactly the most democratic thing getting the universe,
you know?
It's also not good for your,
your ideas of humanity,
right.
You look at when we talk about like human rights violations and poor living
conditions like China is like right up there on that list.
It's helpful.
You know,
as you look down at your Chinese made iPhone,
what a what a motherfucker that is what a mother fucker it is that the,
the minerals that came from that came from even worse conditions.
Some poor African kid digging a hole in the ground and that you need that shit
in order to make a cell phone while you're,
you're googling in Manhattan,
sitting on the corner looking out the window.
You know,
you,
you're the chain of what's happened to get that phone into your hand.
It's a,
it's dirty business at the very end of the chain.
That fancy.
It's fucked up man.
And we don't do anything about that.
You know the then,
well,
we need to get those trainees people more money if you can.
If you,
I don't care if he gave him $1,000 a month,
you know,
which is insane.
And I heard of that's still,
that's still not going to allow them to get the fuck out of there and improve
like that.
They're,
they're stuck.
Let's write,
it cracks me up when I see we men,
we did big giant [inaudible] golfing engagement.
That's shit.
And I'm like,
okay,
that's about what,
27 young kids or 28 how many is,
yeah.
And not only that,
that's shits in warehouses.
We've got the,
the,
the diamond people,
they got that shit locked down.
They're so brilliant.
Those diamond people,
they've managed to get people to pay for like stupid little shiny rocks and
paste incredible money.
I remember that commercial that they used to have isn't three years salary or
three months salary.
A small price to pay for a lifetime,
like three months for a rock.
Want you to work for three months or one rock.
Ooh,
three months.
It should be like a house.
And the old homesteading days,
if you worked for three months,
he built a house.
Yup.
Three months for a fucking shiny rock.
Holy Shit.
Which by the way,
you can make it just a shiny looking the exact same way and you'll have to look
through a glass to make sure it's not the original,
but no,
it's not real.
It's one of my favorite things about the rap culture is like big giant diamond
encrusted necklaces,
diamond chains and diamonds on the rings diamond and the teeth and diamonds in
their ears.
Like I love the bounce back from poverty to extreme wealth and how,
you know,
how flashy they are.
It's what,
to me,
one of the most fascinating aspects of humanity is like they're really over
showy rap guys.
Like throwing money on each other and standing in front of Ferrari's,
you know,
flexing their diamond rings.
Like fucking love it man.
I love it.
Check it bitch.
You know,
it's just,
it's so fascinating.
And then there's,
you know,
people that are like of a old wealth like Prince Charles who would think that
would be garrish behavior and beyond embarrassing,
you know,
I would love to see a reality show where little Wayne had to live with Prince
Charles Lowe weighing it gets Prince Charles high as fuck.
And they go play Polo.
Hold on with flavor and Prince and Prince Charles talks,
any shit little Wayne goes,
you know,
they can't save you.
You know,
Right.
Who were you talking to?
No one did you ever see that interview where he's talking to the guy,
they go there,
they're doing a interrogation of him.
They're there for some fucking subpoena or something like that.
I know they're,
they're questioning him and the,
the question,
the guy's asking them a bunch of stupid questions.
So like he gets gangster with a guy and he goes,
you know,
he can't save you in the real world.
He can't save you.
I'm just letting you know.
And the guy's like,
what?
Are you threatening me?
He goes,
no,
not at all.
Just let you know.
They can't say it's like,
it's really creepy.
Has got Tattoos on his face and fucking giant rang sign from the street.
Do you have people in your school that come from varying economic backgrounds?
They up.
You see the difference between people that come from like really poor countries
and made it to America and really appreciate the fucking shit out of it.
More than these sloppy people from Orange County.
They're living in Irvine their whole life.
Never even seen a bullet.
Yeah man.
I mean there's,
there's bullets.
That's what makes it fun.
You'll get people off officially community college.
It's awesome because you've got people to a full ages.
You got people lethal [inaudible] February,
religions can call you name it,
you know,
so you find all sort of from the guy who was coming straight from South Santa
Hotels,
I'm sorry I got to late,
but there was,
they lock up my blog because they shot some dude on there,
my house,
and they're like,
fuck,
okay.
That's what you come to school,
the weight and the wine was like straight out of Beverly Hills.
It's like,
it's hilarious.
really,
you guys sitting in the same class,
those Compton dudes hook up with those Beverly hills checks and fuck you was
really not.
No,
no,
no.
See,
some of them want to take a trip to the dark side,
especially when they're like in school and they're experimenting right now.
It's my experiencing someone from a different culture.
I mean,
I'm just so amazed by these urban environments that you grew up in.
Yeah.
That actually,
is there a theme to today?
I think there might be.
I need to check off before I do this podcast.
The,
um,
the,
the most satisfying aspect of teaching for you as what?
It's the interaction with the people that's interacting with students.
He's fun.
You know,
that's one of those moments where he's like,
really?
Somebody pay me to talk about stuff I like with people who are cool.
Are you kidding me?
I mean,
which lottery did I wait?
This is too cool to be through.
So you're doing that as well with your podcast.
Uh,
for,
for those who don't know,
it's called a drunk in Dallas and Dallas is spelled with a t you fucking
imbeciles
undereducated Americans.
Um,
and you could go to a iTunes and it's in a,
the philosophy section right where it's at.
Yeah.
That could not give me to date,
even philosophy after two episodes where like for a few days where number wining
food,
also food.
Sure.
Granted the fact is probably the other three people in that category are people
who are broadcasting out of their mom's basement discussing the subtotal
differences between Nagel and Aristotle.
But still it's still first in something that it was fun.
That's amazing.
And that's after how many weeks?
It was like the sec on that piece of the,
so,
you know,
then you got the bounce after a few days it goes down and all of that before a
few days we were like,
number one.
I'm like,
shit,
this is awesome.
How does the Itunes,
uh,
how do they measure?
They have design beauty in sinks.
They have,
it's by episode.
So whichever APP is that.
I think he a week at the most heats.
So of course all the more recent ones tend to be the more popular one because
the more people at least in a week and then they have a gender,
I think podcast history or Sam,
see where they measure the Avodah.
Jeff,
there are so many,
but I don't know exactly how they keep their statistics.
It's subscribers,
new subscribers,
new comments,
nude in downloads.
You know what else it is crashed.
I tunes his fucking crash right now.
God dammit.
Apple.
I think application not responding.
Brian.
Brian then upgraded to your snow leopard.
Yet.
Listen,
son of a bitch.
I like to keep shit old school.
I'm tired of them.
What?
They updates.
It's working.
It's working fine.
Stupid.
Stop changing things and allowing the government to look at my emails.
See My dick pictures that I send myself.
More Dick Board folks,
I'm not gonna lie to Ya.
We might've got a little high before the show.
I'm not going to lie to you.
Some of this might be silly.
Never happens.
Navara why would you with Daniela Bolelli ever.
That is one advantage though that you must have with the ladies is that accent
man,
chicks love a very good European French,
English,
some along those lines.
But Italian woof is pretty good,
right?
I'm very unfair advantage.
I must have think.
Yes,
look at that.
Being honest with us.
You went that good grade.
I'm looking,
I'm going to look under philosophy.
See where you at right now.
Do you know?
No,
I didn't check in a few days.
I didn't even see philosophy.
I see religion and spirituality,
science and medicine.
It's under our society and culture and society and culture.
I think we deem that day.
That seems like life.
How can you have society and I mean,
I mean we could have an MMA podcast and it could be under society and culture.
That was actually the funny thing of the first,
uh,
you know,
precisely.
I mean I'm under society and culture.
The Joe Rogan experience,
society,
culture socket,
let's Id the tags that are ridiculous because they are like,
it's about most of it.
Unless you're really dedicating a podcast specifically to one issue.
It's about life.
That's what it boils down to.
That as it should be,
right?
Yeah.
As it should be.
The um,
the name of the podcast again is drunk and Taoist and I can't find it in here
and what I can't find philosophy.
Is there a specific section that says philosophy?
The philosophy.
You've got it.
Yeah.
There it goes.
It's a subsection of a subsection.
Yay.
I'll call as for a few days.
The first thing,
that subsection of the first subsection,
but I'm not anymore so that's pretty dope.
What number are you right now?
I have no idea.
I was like seeks a few days ago,
but that's,
I'm sure it bounced out cause we haven't done a new one.
If you say son,
we're going to change that shit for you.
We're going to find it.
I can't find it.
I don't know where it is,
but it's drunken Taoist,
You heard me?
That's how you spell it.
You freaks.
I'll put a link up to it on a,
on Twitter and a man.
Thanks so much brother.
Thank you very much man.
Another fun and fascinating podcasts or waste my drunken Dallas Danieli will
Ellie,
you're,
you're a good man.
Danieli always good to talk to you,
brother.
Joe,
if there's ever anything we can do for you or anything you want to promote and
please let us know.
Uh,
thank you to everybody tuning into the podcast.
Thanks to a,
all the positive energy,
all the love and all the information that you guys give me an a feedback and all
that shit.
We're getting through this all together.
And uh,
I would not be able to do it without you and I would not have the same feeling
without all the love and all the,
the,
the positive reactions and all the,
the positive response that we get.
We appreciate the fuck out of it.
And I know Brian does and I know everybody else.
Does.
Joey and Orient Doc,
can we talk about it all the time?
We,
we love the fuck out of you guys.
Thank you very much.
Thanks to all the sponsors.
You know who the fuck you are.
I'm not saying you at the end anymore,
goddammit.
But a go to death squad.
Dot TV.
Um,
uh,
that's Brian's site and that's how you get yourself one of those sweet
psychedelic kittycat tee shirts that I see at all the shows now.
And I saw him in Montreal.
It was fucking awesome.
It was,
it's beautiful when I,
when I look out there and that audience,
when I see those death squad shirts,
I know him.
And,
uh,
I'm know I'm winning.
You're good family.
Um,
with family,
his mother Fucker,
that was his,
that was his long,
long game.
That was his checkmate from a long distance.
I'm going to be a in San Diego Wednesday by Doug Benson now.
Powerful American comedy.
Beautiful.
And uh,
I will be here with Joey Diaz Wednesday night,
the night before Thanksgiving,
uh,
at the ice house comedy.
We've got a 10 o'clock show.
Greg Fitzsimmons is going to be there.
Adam Hunter who wrote that joke that I got in trouble telling on Fx to really
get in trouble.
It caused a commotion.
And,
uh,
you know,
I said a joke that Adam Hunter had a really funny joke about Martin Kampmann and
he said,
Martin from behind it,
it's it,
but it's a funny fucking joke,
be upset because there's,
you know,
children listening and so I didn't even think about it.
I'm an idiot.
Oh comedian.
Okay.
But the Pipi what bothers me that people called it homophobic and a,
that is not a homophobic joke.
Okay.
Because anything that's gay,
if you mentioned something gay,
it's automatically deemed to be negative.
I joke about you're not even supposed to joke about things that are gay or gay
sex or anything and he won.
That's gay.
Cause if you do somehow it's a negative,
I think.
I say,
fuck you.
that's stupid.
That is absolutely ridiculous.
Everything is on the table.
As long as you know,
you have good intentions.
And my intention was only to make people laugh and it was a,
because Adam Hunter is a funny dude and he'll be on the show a Wednesday as well
as,
uh,
like I said,
Greg Fitzsimmons,
Joey Diaz,
Sam triple,
he's going to be there.
And,
uh,
we'll find some other cool guys,
that are in town,
um,
that,
uh,
our,
local standups,
but 10 o'clock,
15 bucks at the Icehouse,
go to icehouse comedy.com and come down to see us.
And,
uh,
Brian Red band has been added to the Fabulous Austin Texas show at the movie
theater December 1st.
Lot of you folks,
you're like,
God,
I want to see him in person and so excited thought she hear about his loads.
Um,
frothy loads,
uh,
that yeah,
we're going to have a good time.
That's a December 1st at the Moody Theater in Austin,
Texas and I will be there with Joey Diaz and Duncan trussell's coming as well.
So it should be a hell of a fucking show.
Um,
yeah,
we're going to have a good fucking time,
Texas.
And that's where we're setting up Camp Rogan.
That's where death squad,
uh,
survival camp's gonna be.
We're gonna,
we're gonna have a fucking fenced in area and keep alive animals in there.
Fucks fucking,
I'm rambling.
It's official again.
That's when it's time to shut the music off.
I will see you guys tomorrow with Les Stroud.
Survivor man is going to be here tomorrow.
Fuck yes.
I'm very exciting.
Very exciting.
Um,
I'm a very Brazilian,
a very exciting for you.
Little butcher in my own fucking language is not my language.
God Damn.
And I'm not claiming it.
Les Stroud from survivor man and he's gonna bring his band a less,
well,
at least some people to play with them cause he's,
he's,
he's got some music that's being released and a,
and he's just an all around cool motherfucker.
I can't wait to talk to him.
And then Wednesday,
one of,
one of the funniest guys in the country,
Greg Proops is going to be joining us and that will be our final podcast for the
week before the lovely holiday of Thanksgiving where we all celebrate syphilis
covered blankets and fucking,
I shouldn't have said that.
Good night everybody.
It's over.
Kiss your mother,
your neighbors,
pet your dog,
spread that love you sons of bitches.
CSO.
Okay.